[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement Laurent
Morel ?
Laurent Morel, ben moi je suis
vice-président du Chief Project et et
copromoteur et auteur de ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française
avec toute l'équipe The Shift.
Voilà. Et puis par ailleurs, moi j'ai
une carrière plutôt d'entrepreneur. J'ai
dirigé il y a quelques années une grande
foncière de centres commerciaux, ce qui
me destinait tout particulièrement
à m'occuper ensuite de la transition
énergétique évidemment. Voilà. Donc et
donc petit passage sur le CAC 40.
Petit passage sur le CAC 40. Oui, parce
que quand on est dans dans ce monde de
la grande entreprise, on a la chance de
de cro de voir ce monde de la finance,
hein.
Alors, j'ai été nommé président de
Clépierre le 1er janvier 2009,
un moment intéressant pour la finance
internationale. Donc, j'ai connu
pas mal de développement à cette
époque-là et c'était une expérience
vraiment intéressante. très heureux de
l'avoir fait, assez content de l'avoir
quitté aussi et puis de m'occuper de
sujets,
voilà qui sont plus existentiels, on va
dire.
Jean-Marc
euh donc Jean-Marc Jeankovici euh je
suis président du chiffre project et par
ailleurs comme à la fois l'activité de
vice-président et l'activité de
président sont les activités bénévoles,
euh ce qui me nourrit c'est d'être
associé de Carbone 4, ce qui est
également le cas de de Laurent. Euh et
puis par ailleurs, j'ai quelques petites
activités annexes. Donc je suis membre
du haut conseil pour le climat mais
évidemment je n'engage absolument pas
cette institution quand je m'exprime. Et
je suis par ailleurs professeur amine
Paritech et je n'engage pas non plus
cette institution quand je m'exprime. En
fait, je ne m'exprime qu'en mon nom mais
voilà les quelques activités qui
m'occupent.
Donc on a décidé de vous faire venir ce
soir parce que vos travaux sont
intimement liés à notre prisme de
lecture et je pense devrait être
intimement lié à tous les prismes de
lecture. Vous travaillez beaucoup sur
l'énergie, les matières premières, la
transition énergétique, la transition
écologique. C'est un sujet qui est clé.
Donc on va commencer un petit peu par
vous secouer.
Alors les boomers, est-ce que votre
petit rapport c'est pas une façon
d'absoudre votre âme de boomer ?
Ça serait beaucoup de travail pour ça.
C'est parce que vous avez beaucoup pêché
euh ou c'est parce qu'on a
nécessairement beaucoup pêché. De toute
façon, tant qu'on ne sait pas, on pêche.
Voilà. Après, il faut il faut savoir euh
très honnêtement, il y a toujours un
petit côté comme ça. De toute façon,
quand on change d'orientation dans une
vie, hein, c'est
je pense que les gens qui ne le
reconnaissent pas quelque part
n'acceptent pas de le dire, mais il y a
toujours une petite part comme ça.
Maintenant, on l'a pas fait que pour ça
et surtout, on l'a pas fait que nous.
Donc derrière ce travail qui a été fait
par le chiffre Project, il y a
énormément de gens qui ont pas du tout
notre âge, qui sont heureusement pour
eux beaucoup plus jeunes qui ont
travaillé, qui ont construit, qui ont
bâti touses ces propositions, toutes ces
propositions pardon. Euh et par
ailleurs, même si on est boomer, grâce
au miracle de la médecine, on espère
bien qu'on reviendra ici dans 50 ans.
Donc euh on a encore nous aussi une
vision de l'avenir euh on on peut dire
euh on a une un prisme enfin comment
dire une prise directe avec la
génération qui nous suit parce qu'on a
des enfants. Donc voilà euh ça compte un
tout petit peu. Et donc et par ailleurs
pour finir le le ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française,
il comporte un volet opérationnel qui
porte sur le prochain quinquena et on
espère tous les deux qu'on sera toujours
vivant à la fin du prochain quinquena.
Donc
déjà, on va essayer de vous garder
vivant avant la fin de cette interview.
Euh pour bien comprendre pour les les
novices qui nous rejoignent et qui ne
connaissent pas du tout le sujet, vous
avez fait ce ce plan
parce que le réchauffement climatique,
ça commence à poser problème. J'ai
l'impression que le l'épuisement des
matières premières, ça commence aussi à
poser problème. Donc avant de commencer
pour déployer vos préconisations, je
voudrais que Jean-Marc nous fasse un
état des lieux. Et si on ne fait rien,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Alors déjà, je réfute l'expression si on
ne fait rien parce que on fait quelque
chose, on fait on
continue sur cette lancée.
Oui, c'est ça. On fait ce qu'on faisait
avant à quelques aménagements près.
Euh ce que les les risques ou plus
exactement les contraintes qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui viennent du fait que
malheureusement la planète ne peut pas
augmenter de taille un ballon de foot
avec un coup de pompe à vélo approprié.
Et donc on est sur un terrain de jeu euh
qui possède un certain nombre de limites
alors qu'il y a énormément d'avantages
et quand même plein de trucs sympas sur
cette planète mais qui possède un
certain nombre de limites. Et ces
limites viennent souvent de choses qui
relèvent de la biologie, de la physique,
de la chimie, donc de lois qui dépendent
pas de nous ou de contraintes externes
qui dépendent pas de nous. Alors les il
y a une limite que je qualifie d'amont,
c'est-à-dire celle qui porte sur tout ce
qui rentre dans le système productif. Et
ça ça concerne l'énergie qui met en
route les machines qui produisent pour
nous. Ça concerne les ressources qui
rentrent dans les machines. Alors,
notamment les ressources minérales, euh
les métaux ou les ou les le calcaire
pour faire du ciment. Ça concerne
éventuellement l'espace disponible pour
disposer de ressources vivantes. Donc la
biomasse qui demande de l'espace pour
pousser. Et puis en sortie, on a des
limites, on va dire d'épuration. Les
déchets, historiquement, on a toujours
eu que deux manières de les gérer. On
les dilue dans l'environnement ou bien
on les concentre et on les stock quelque
part. Euh historiquement, on a dilué, on
diluait tout dans l'environnement et
puis euh quand vraiment on pouvait plus
diluer dans l'environnement, on stock et
on et enfin on concentre et on stock. Et
dans les déchets qu'on produit
aujourd'hui qu'on dilue dans
l'environnement, il y a notamment le gaz
carbonique et autres gaz à effet de
serre. Et il y a une autre limite, c'est
que la poubelle atmosphérique ne peut
pas en absorber plus que ça, une
certaine limite à la quantité qu'elle
peut absorber avant de créer une dérive
climatique qui va fortement déstabiliser
des conditions qui étaient quasi stables
depuis 10000 ans et qui ont permis
l'émergence de la civilisation
sédentaire que nous connaissons. Donc
c'est ça les c'est ça le cadre dans
lequel on joue. Alors si on ne fait
rien, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Le monde
ne continue pas éternellement comme il
est aujourd'hui. C'est bien ça le
problème. La déplession des ressources
minérales et de l'énergie s'applique.
Donc à un moment, on a de moins en moins
de ressources pour faire fonctionner
notre système productif. Et par
ailleurs, les problèmes environnementaux
s'accroissent et à un moment en retour,
ils ont un effet sur la taille de la
population et son espérance de vie. Donc
voilà. Voilà. En gros, alors par plein
de moyens divers et variés, il peut y
avoir des dises, il peut y avoir des
maladies, il peut y avoir des conflits,
il peut y avoir enfin voilà des
événements extrêmes, enfin tout un tas
de trucs. Et donc le si on ne fait rien,
en fait, on s'expose de façon croissante
à ce que le système se régule à nos
dépends, c'est-à-dire via des surprises
et le dictionnaire est bien fait. Une
surprise, c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
pas venir à l'avance. comme un signe
noir
un peu exactement un peu comme un signe
noir. Euh c'était même pas de la pub
pour la chaîne. Euh mais c'est
exactement ça qu'on risque. C'est-à-dire
qu'on risque d'avoir en quantité
croissante des choses inattendues qui
vont s'exercer à nos dépend et nous
forcer à ne plus, j'ai envie de dire,
prélever autant ou perturber autant
l'environnement. Simplement, c'est des
modes qu'on aura pas choisis et en
général, c'est toujours plus désagréable
que les modes qu'on a choisis. Un peu
comme la thermodynamique quand ça
devient instable.
Oui. Alors, il y a une loi en chimie qui
s'appelle la loi de le Châelier qui dit
que tout système hors d'équilibre a
envie d'y revenir. Bah là, on peut
essayer d'appliquer cette loi. J'ai
envie de dire, à l'humanité.
Aujourd'hui, l'humanité est hors
d'équilibre vis-à-vis de son
environnement et donc à un moment ça va
y revenir et il vaudrait mieux que ça y
revienne en ayant un peu réfléchi à la
question et avec des choses qu'on décide
de faire nous plutôt que ça y revienne
avec des choses qui échappent totalement
à notre contrôle.
Alors, vous êtes venu ce soir avec un
partenaire qui a travaillé dans la
finance, qui connaît un petit peu la
finance, qui doit connaître, je pense,
aussi les marchés financiers.
Oui.
Euh,
les marchés financiers, Laurent, est-ce
qu'ils ont une capacité d'anticipation
ou c'est un petit peu des petits joueurs
qui courent après le profil, le
rendement, quoi qu'il arrive, quoi qu'il
en coûte ?
Je vais j'explique pourquoi on a fait
venir quelqu'un de la finance.
Ouais. Une transformation ne se fera pas
sur les marchés pour reuter les flux
financiers. Nous sommes d'accord.
Bah, c'est peut-être de ça dont il faut
qu'on parle.
Et ben,
je vous donne la parole. Alors,
alors bah d'abord la le monde de
l'économie, moi j'ai fait pas mal de
choses dans ma vie. J'ai je me suis
occupé de voiture, je me suis occupé de
camion, je me suis occupé d'immobilier,
je me suis occupé de retail. Et donc
c'est
le retail ici,
le retail c'est le commerce. Voilà,
c'est
ça fait ça fait in de de ça.
Non, mais dans dans le monde dans lequel
on était, ça sa cause mais pardon pour
ce jargon. Et donc en fait oui, toute
l'économie est concernée par les
transformations qui évoquent qui
évoquait Jean-Marc. C'estàd que les
conditions d'exercice de toutes les
activités économiques sont remises en
cause par la transition. absolument
toutes euh et pas que les sociétés
pétrolières, l'industrie lourde,
absolument tous les tous les usages et
toutes les consommations sont
concernées.
Donc en fait, on y reviendra peut-être
tout à l'heure, mais la finance, la
conception qu'on peut avoir de la
finance,
euh
moi en tout cas celle que j'ai, c'est
que la finance est miroir de l'économie
réelle.
Euh la finance c'est la façon la finance
la façon de donner une valeur à
l'instant à une transaction hein. C'est
une convention à un moment donné entre
un producteur de service ou de bien et
quelqu'un qui l'achète le créage
spéculatif.
Alors la spéculation c'est autre chose
mais à l'instanté au moment de la
transaction c'est d'abord une convention
hein.
Donc je crois qu'il faut prendre la
finance pour ce qu'elle est. Il faut pas
lui faire porter ni des fautes, ni des
responsabilités, ni une capacité à
transformer.
Pourquoi il faut pas leur faire porter
des fou ?
On peut mais si on veut
on peut leur Ça c'est on a le droit de
le faire mais si on veut essayer de
comprendre parce qu'on est là pour
essayer de comprendre, on n'est pas là
pour essayer de faire porter la faute à
l'autre peut-être.
Vous avez encore des des intérêts dans
finances ?
Non, pas plus que mes activités.
Non non. Donc
non, je crois que ce qui est intéressant
dans la finance, c'est qu'elle est le
miroir des choses, hein. Elle elle
prétend d'ailleurs
avoir plus de pouvoir qu'elle n'en a. On
entend parler de financement à impact,
de mettez l'argent chez moi et je
l'investirai
dans des activités qui sont favorables à
la transition ou à l'égalité et cetera.
En vérité, la finance, elle reflète,
elle ne fait que s'adosser, s'investir
sur des choses qui existent,
des activités commerciales, des
services, des biens de l'immobilier, des
dettes d'État. Elle ne fait que refléter
l'économie réelle.
Les dettes d'État, on reparlera des
agences de notation d'ailleurs.
Oui.
Et vous voulez continuer votre propos ?
On y reviendra sur la finance puisque on
en a parlé dans notre dans notre plan de
transformation de l'accadémie française.
Jean-Marc,
pour être tout à fait clair,
votre plan, parce que il faut un plan
face à un danger, il faut une stratégie,
il
faut être proactif.
Quels sont les angles morts ?
Les angles morts, ils sont euh alors ce
qu'on a essayé de faire pour pour ce
plan, c'est de considérer que il fallait
avoir une feuille de route par secteur.
Euh les secteurs, on les a pris alors on
les a définis de manière un peu,
on va dire, c'est c'est pas totalement
joinf et de temps en temps, il y a des
il y a des trucs qui se recouvrent un
peu, mais les secteurs, on les a définis
soit par rapport à des usages, par
exemple se loger ou se déplacer. Donc on
a des chapitres dans le plan qui
concernent le logement, on a des
chapitres qui concernent la mobilité
longue distance, la mobilité du
quotidien euh qui par exemple la
mobilité longue distance et du quotidien
sont traités séparément parce que ça
correspond pas du tout aux mêmes usages.
Euh
pour rendre le propos encore plus euh
sexy,
ce rapport est fait pour décroître de 5
% de production de gaz carbonique par
an.
Oui.
Pour éviter qu'on aille droit dans le
mur en terme de réchauffement climatique
avec mouvement de population, famille.
Je vais commencer par répondre à la
première question. Est-ce qu'il y a des
angles bords ? J'ai dis oui.
Donc le donc les usages sont pas les
mêmes, c'est ça que j'étais en train de
dire. Et par exemple, l'usage de
mobilité longue distance, c'est
essentiellement un usage loisir. L'usage
mobilité du quotidien, c'est
essentiellement travail, course, école
contraint, on va dire. C'est il y a des
choses beaucoup plus contraintes. Donc
on a séparé les deux. On a dit on va pas
aller travers. Euh il y a un usage qui
est mangé, donc il y a un chapitre sur
et puis il y a un usage récréatif, la
culture. Bah on l'a traité en tant que
tel. On aurait pu traiter la culture
comme de l'immobilier parce que c'est
des cinémas, c'est des bâtiments, des
déplacements parce que aller au cinéma
c'est de la bagnole et cetera. Et c'est
pas ça qu'on a fait, on a traité. Voilà.
Donc ça, il y a des choses qui se
recouvrent. Puis il y a des choses qu'on
a pas traité en tant que tel. Par
exemple, le tourisme, on l'a pas traité
en tant que tel. Il y a des secteurs
industriels qu'on a mal couvert. Voilà,
ça c'est ça a été un bah par exemple une
partie de l'industrie manufacturière,
elle est pas bien couverte. Le textile
est pas bien couvert, enfin ou pas
couvert du tout. Donc c'est un c'est une
première ébauche. Euh on a fait ce qu'on
a pu en 2 ans, il y a quelques
centaines. Euh mais euh oui, il y a un
sujet argent, pas que euh parce que il y
a aussi un sujet méthode et conception.
C'est-à-dire que il y a des gens à qui
vous pouvez donner des centaines de
millions et de toute façon, ils
avanceront pas parce que ils ont pas les
bonnes méthodes et la bonne non mais pas
la bonne manière de rentrer dans le
parler de la finance. Non.
Oui,
pas nécessairement. Ça peut être la
finance, ça peut être des gens qui ont
pas le Ça peut être des gens qui sont
prisonniers de leurs intérêts et on les
tous en fait. On a tous on a tous Non
mais on a tous des intérêts, on a tous
une dépendance. L'indépendance, ça
existe pas. C'est une vue d'esprit. Euh
nous, on essaie d'être transparent mais
on peut pas être indépendant. Ça existe
pas l'indépendance.
Euh on a tous un banquier, une source de
revenu,
un bagage culturel, tous dépend de
quelque chose.
Des salariés,
des salariés parfois. Absolument.
Absolument. On en a on en est dépendant.
Et donc le voilà. Donc il y a des angles
morts en terme de domaines qui ont pas
pu être couverts. Il y a des angles
morts au sens où il y a des dom il y a
des secteurs sur lesquels on n' pas eu
le temps d'aller jusqu'à des mesures
très opérationnelles. Donc on on avance
sur ce chemin et cetera. Donc
nécessairement la profondeur de de
pénétration est un peu inhomogène euh
selon selon les secteurs. Par contre, il
y a pas d'angle mort sur la méthode
qu'on a utilisé qui est toujours la même
euh qui est de rentrer dans le problème
sous l'angle physique. C'estàd que on on
n'est pas rentré dans le problème sous
l'angle économique. Donc on n' pas
commencé par se dire justement qu'on
faire ce qui vient d'être dit euh par le
rang. Est-ce qu'il y aura est-ce que les
marchés vont nous donner de l'argent ?
Ça c'est pas notre problème. Dans un
premier temps, on a on a pris le
problème sous langue physique puisque en
face nous avons un problème physique. Et
le problème physique que nous avons,
c'est effectivement de baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Parce que l'accord de Paris qui nous dit
il faut éviter que la Terre se réchauffe
de plus de 2 degrés à une contrepartie
qui est ça veut dire physiquement que
les émissions doivent baisser de 5 % par
an. Et donc nous on a dit chiche, on va
regarder ce que ça veut dire. Donc en
fait ce plan il a comme première entrée
si on est sérieux sur la question
climatique et si on fait notre part dans
cette affaire, voilà le genre de
réorganisation qu'il faut mettre en
route et voilà le genre de gain qu'il
faut qu'on ait dans les 5 ans. C'est
c'est ça c'est ça le c'est ça le cahier
des charges.
Laurent, vous voulez rebondir ?
Ouais. Si je rebondis sur l'exemple de
la mobilité courte distance et la
mobilité longue distance
et les anglements, vous avez des des ch
je reviens après mais juste pour
rebondir sur ce que dit Jean-Marc, quand
on regarde la mobilité, on a on a il y a
ces deux usages différents. Aujourd'hui,
la mobilité pendulaire courte distance
80 % de l'usage de la voiture et
20 % de l'usage, c'est la mobilité
longue distance pour faire simple. Et
pourtant, on dimensionne le véhicule
aujourd'hui, on le on le cube en poids,
en puissance machin pour euh la longue
distance. Donc aujourd'hui, c'est
suboptimal en terme de rationalisation
des émissions. Vous
êtes sûr de votre coup, on design on
designe pas les véhicules un petit peu
pour
faire rêver. Oui, on fait vroom mais on
fait on fait plus vroom avec un SUV qui
fait 1 tonne 7 qui peut aller à 180 à
l'heure et qui permet d'aller l'hiver à
Saint-Gervet l'été à Biaritz
pour 5 % de la population.
Ouais, pour plus que ça. Le la mobilité
longue distance c'est donc et
aujourd'hui le véhicule est dimensionné
de fait pour cet usage qui est marginal
donc c'est suboptimal.
Donc au fond quand on trans quand on
fait cette rationalisation de l'usage de
l'automobile, on va distinguer l'usage
courte distance sur lequel on va aller
chercher des solutions de transport en
commun, de micromobilité électrique, de
vélo et cetera sur lequel on va avoir
une baisse massive de l'empreinte et des
émissions pour cet usage- là. Et puis on
va aller chercher une autre solution
pour la mobilité de longue distance qui
repose sur plus de trains, sur des
véhicules les mêmes à destination et
cetera. Donc le travail qu'a fait le
PTF, c'est ça, c'est un travail de
PTF qui veut dire plan
plan de transformation de l'économie
française, qui est pas formidable comme
nom. Euh finalement, on l'appelle il
nous faut un plan pour faire simple où
on est bientôt à la rue où c'est on va
cramer.
Ouais. Quelque chose comme ça. Voilà, il
nous faut un plan.
Sauf qu'il peut. Il nous faut un plan.
Ouais. Et donc voilà le comment on
rationalise le plan, c'est par usage et
par usage on optimise.
Alors en terme d'angle mort, on va juste
effuiller deux trois choses.
L'aspect défense, vous l'avez creusé un
peu ?
Non.
L'aspect sécurité, vous l'avez creusé un
peu ?
Pas en tant que tel. Administration
publique, on a regardé, on a fait
travailler parce que comme le disait
Jean-Marc, dans chacun de ces secteurs,
on n pas travaillé tout seul. On a une
équipe de permanents, on a des bénévoles
et puis on a surtout fait une sorte de
consultation citoyenne intrsectorielle à
chaque fois qu'on a fait travailler des
dizaines et des dizaines de gens
sympathisants qui nous ont aidé à
concevoir ce que la décarbonation
voulait dire pour leur propre secteur
hein. Donc dans l'administration
publique, on a eu un très grand nombre
de gens qui étaient les mieux placés
pour dire "J'ai bien compris le
problème. Bah dans dans ma fonction à
moi, voilà ce que ça veut dire la
réduction de 5 % par an." Donc dans
administration publique, oui, il y a une
partie euh des gens de la défense qui se
sont exprimés à ce titre-là.
Euh l'aspect psychologique de cette
transition, est-ce que vous l'avez
abordé ? Est-ce que vous avez émis des
préconisations pour euh, je vais dire
euh changer les mentalités ? Une une
propagande, que ce soit de guerre, que
ce soit une propagande économique,
nécessite un impact et une une adhérence
de la population. Est-ce que vous avez
creusé ça ? Est-ce que vous avez nudgé
un petit peu ? Alors, on est en train de
le faire en ce moment un peu. Euh c'est
là, on rentre, j'ai envie de dire, dans
un domaine qui n'est plus le domaine de
l'ingénieur, qui est un qui est plus le
domaine de la de la quantité,
qui est le domaine du désir, qui est le
domaine de la norme sociale, qui est le
domaine de l'adhésion, qui est le
domaine du bien-être et cetera. Donc là,
on a mis quelques éléments en disant
c'est absolument indispensable euh et en
fait, il faut trouver les voies et
moyens de rendre un certain nombre de
choses désirables euh et pas juste
obligatoire euh parce que pour le moment
euh on on c'est indispensable pour que
le les gens avancent. J'ai envie de dire
ça, c'est un peu du travail en cours.
C'est-à-dire que je redi euh il a il
faut quand même comprendre que il a
fallu deux siècles pour perfectionner la
civilisation fossile dans laquelle on
vit. et même on a hérité avant ça de
quelques réflexes qu'on avait depuis
bien plus longtemps se taper sur la
gueule
ou alors ça malheureusement il faut
éviter mais c'est un réflexe qu'on a oui
de temps en temps c'est évident et en
tout cas c'est un grand risqu
c'est-à-dire que le risque de se
retrouver pris au dépourvu par un manque
de ressources ça l'histoire pas pas
besoin de creuser très longtemps les
livres d'histoire pour comprendre que
l'un des risques évidents derrière c'est
le conflit
euh intérieur ou entre pays
enfin c'est ça non mais je veux dire ça
peut trè bien de la guerre civile. Ça ça
peut ça peut voilà, on a malheureusement
l'histoire a montré que et en
particulier dans notre pays, on savait
très bien faire ça.
Donc le
donc ce que la question de encore une
fois de la désirabilité de l'affaire, on
a posé le cadre en disant faut que ça
soit le cas. On a commencé à faire en
marge de ce plan de transformation de
l'économie française. On avait fait une
consultation un peu large que en bon
français on a appelé la Big Review.
Quoi ? Bah la grande revue quoi. Voilà.
Pour
ne pas le dire sur Sy Review d'ailleurs
parce que parce que on aurait dû mais on
aurait dû mais on va on a enfin on va y
revenir parce que le cette première
cette première passe c'était une
première passe, c'est pas totalement
satisfaisant. On a eu des trucs très
intéressants mais c'était pas évidemment
pas satisfaant, pas suffisant. Et donc
on a organisé des milliers de ce qu'on a
appelé des discussions euh où il y a une
personne qui allait en voir
quelques-unes euh en leur disant pas
beaucoup 10 20 en leur disant bah voilà
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à ce genre de
truc ? Qu'est-ce que vous préférez ceci
plutôt que cela, qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ça ? Et cetera. Et on on si je
prends un parallèle, c'est des espèces
de micro mini convention citoyenne,
quoi. C'est c'est ça l'idée. Donc on met
les gens ensemble et puis on essaie de
voir à quel type de consensus ils
arrivent, comment est-ce que ils
réagent.
C'est mis derrière la
Oui. Et c'est indispensable. Alors,
c'est indispensable à plein de titres.
C'est indispensable, et vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir parce que discuter
de ce genre de sujet, ça peut pas se
faire en 3 minutes. Euh c'est toujours
long que les gens évoluent, ça leur
demande aussi plus de les les les
convictions toutes prêtes, elles
n'emporte personne. Il faut que les gens
ils viennent par eux-mêmes.
Euh sauf si on les a formé pendant
longues années dans leur jeunesse en
leur laissant pas le choix. Mais de
toute façon, c'est long. Euh et donc ce
genre de ce genre de débat euh on a tout
juste commencé à le faire et on va
continuer parce qu'on sait très bien que
c'est une des clés du succès.
Il y a un point quand même sur la
désirabilité de ce plan qu'on a
découvert en en le mettant en place
parce que on s'était dit en fait dans
cette affaire de transformation de
l'économie française, nous notre
constatation de de praticien de cette
transformation quand on rencontre des
entreprises, des groupes de gens et
cetera, c'est que la transition c'est
aussi une affaire de connaissance, de
compréhension des enjeux et de et de
savoir-faire.
Est-ce que la population est capable ?
Pas toujours. Elle est capable de
comprendre mais il faut la former. On
parle beaucoup de par exemple de
transform enfin de rénovation du
bâtiment et on fait des aides et cetera
et en vérité on n'y arrive pas vraiment.
On y arrive pas vraiment parce que c'est
le monde des artisans qui demande à se
former. Il y a il y a beaucoup de gestes
de transformation des bâtiments qui sont
de compétences
compétences, geste, savoir-faire
connaissance. Et donc dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française,
il y a deux ressources qu'on regarde à
équivalence, la ressource naturelle et
la ressource humaine. C'est pas un jeu
de mot. C'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois
quand on fait cette analyse
intrsectorielle, on demande aux gens
comment vous pouvez faire - 5 % de
matériaux, d'énergie et cetera et
quelles compétences il faut que vous
ayez. Quelles sont les compétences que
vous avez aujourd'hui qui s'appliquent
plus dans le monde de demain mais qui
s'appliquerait dans un autre secteur ?
Et il y en a plein. Et donc cette
intelligence là, on en a besoin. C'est
la raison pour laquelle on a eu un écho
extraordinaire du monde syndical. sur ce
plan de transformation de l'économie
française. Alors, si je viens sur la
désirabilité, c'est qu'on s'est rendu
compte aussi que les gens quand ils ont
fait ce travail
sur l'emploi, la compétence, ça les a
passionné parce que notre affaire de
transition, c'est super anxiogène en
fait. Tout le monde se dit "Mais ou là
là, qu'est-ce la solastalgie
Ah oui bon ben j'aurais appris quelque
chose ce soir mais oui enfin la
siigie on va y venir laig mais disons en
tout cas oui enfin ça fait peur quoi
pour
l'alignement des planètes
ah voilà d'accord ok enfin la transition
ça fait peur c'est voilà et donc les
gens se disent en faisant ce travail là
vraiment de l'enthousiasme parce qu'il
se dit mais au fond euh moi dans ce
monde là demain décrit moi j'ai ma place
je je sais quel job je vais avoir et je
sais quel job mes enfants vont avoir.
Pas mal quand même. Donc
le premier désir, c'est quand même de
savoir ce qu'on va être, pas forcément
ce qu'on va consommer.
Les gens, ils sont pas si bêtes que ça.
Donc ils ont quand même envie, ils ont
quand même un une problématique d'abord
de raison d'être, hein. Qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont faire ?
Ou de survie.
Oui.
Oui, mais on peut le prendre
positivement parce que c'est aussi
c'est positif la survie. Oui, ça on a
une ambition au-delà de la survie, hein.
Et donc c'est la la vie bien et la vie
bien dans ce que je vais faire, hein,
dans ce que je vais être. Voilà. Et très
modestement, je pense que ce plan de
transformation français
et ben pourquoi pas ?
Et très modestement, ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française,
oui, il vise aussi à se mettre d'accord
avec les gens dans les secteurs sur ce
qu'ils vont devenir eux. Voilà. Et il y
a beaucoup d'optimisme.
La raison pour laquelle il est très
français, c'est parce que justement je
vais en venir derrière.
On veut justement
on a un plan on a un plan jusqu'au
jusqu'au moment où on se prend une
grosse patate.
Non, c'est pas ça. C'est que on voulait
justement sortir de l'argument
consistant à dire "Mais on ne peut rien
faire parce que l'Europe, parce que le
monde, parce que ceci, parce que cela."
Donc nous, on a pris le problème à
l'envers. On a dit "On va pas regarder
ce qu'on ne peut pas faire, on va
regarder ce qu'on peut faire."
On va faire ce qu'on ce qu'on devrait
faire. Bon, et il y a plein de mesures
là-dedans qui ne dépendent absolument
pas euh de ce que vont décider euh ni
nos voisins euh ni euh les États-Unis,
ni je sais pas quoi. Euh par exemple, je
vais prendre un exemple tout con
puisqu'on parlait du logement tout à
l'heure,
un tout petit peu en lien avec le prix
de l'énergie en ce moment. Si on décide
de chasser le fiou et le gaz du
chauffage des logements français,
c'estd que si Poutine nous coupe le
robinet,
alors j'ai justement, je vais y venir,
je je ne m'occupe pas de Poutine pour le
moment. Ce que je dis c'est euh si on
veut chasser le fioule et le gaz des
logements français, je n'ai pas besoin
de savoir ce que vont faire les
Portugais, les Espagnols, les Canadiens
et les Argentins pour le faire. Je n'ai
pas besoin de réglementation européenne
qui m'oblige à le faire. Ça ne dépend
que de la volonté du gouvernement
français. Ça ne dépend que des mesures
que nous allons mettre en œuvre en
France pour, comme le disait Laurent
tout à l'heure, former les gens qui
doivent faire de façon correcte parce
que pour le moment euh il y a il y a pas
assez de gens qui savent faire pour
aller à la bonne vitesse. Faire émerger
en France une filière de fabrication de
pompe à chaleur, ça c'est pas très
compliqué. Euh et forcer les
propriétaires à changer les organes de
chauffage sur quelques décennies, he on
parle pas de en une semaine,
en aidant ceux qui pourront vraiment pas
et en disant pour les autres bah c'est à
vos frais. Donc c'est exactement comme
ça que on a imaginé un certain nombre de
mesures. Il y a juste pas besoin. Je
vais prendre un autre exemple qui est
celui de la santé. Dans la santé, on a
on propose une santé sobre en moyen. Et
il y a une très bonne manière d'être
sobre en moyen, c'est d'arrêter de faire
des choses qui nous envoient
prématurément à l'hôpital. Bon,
fumer.
Exactement. Donc, il y a fumer, manger
du sucre, euh trop boire, trop de
sédentarité et cetera. Donc en fait
l'essentiel euh on peut beaucoup agir
pour être en meilleure santé sans
augmenter les plateaux techniques des
hôpitaux et même en les diminuant
éventuellement. Bon donc on a pris le
problème un peu dans sa dans sa
globalité. Mettre ça en route ne dépend
pas non plus de ce que vont faire les
Japonais, les Chinois ou les
Indonésiens.
Donc on a on a c'est délibéré queil y
ait marqué français dessus comme le
Camemberber. C'est pas juste parce que
on dit ah dans le monde mondialisé. Non,
justement, on on on veut faire notre
part, c'est-à-dire proposer des choses
qui sont à notre main et pas encore une
fois se retrancher derrière "Ah mais
tant que mes concurrents ont pas bougé,
moi je peux rien faire." Voilà.
Ou l'Europe
ou l'Europe ou je sais pas qui
ou la finance qui fera pas ce qu'il
faut.
Et un dernier exemple qui est alors là,
il y a une nouvelle en plus dans
l'actualité qui vient de tomber euh qui
concerne l'acier euh dans la partie
industrie lourde euh du plan. Donc il
faut voir savoir que l'industrie lourde
en France c'est les tris/4 des émissions
industrielles. Alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans l'industrie lourde ? C'est la
fabrication des matériaux de base
essentiellement acier, un/art des
émissions françaises, chimie plastique
et autres produit 1/4 et enfin ciment
1/4 pour dire les choses de façon ciment
chaud enfin et cetera 1/4 donc ça ça ces
troisl font des 3/4 et puis tout le
reste fait 1/4 d'accord
euh donc dans les donc on a
essentiellement attaqué ces trois
secteurs là et dans l'acier on dit par
exemple une chose qu'il faut faire c'est
de réduire le minerai de fer à
l'hydrogène au lieu de le réduire au
charbon donc en gros le miner de fer,
c'est de l'oxyde de fer, hein. C'est du
du fer et de l'oxygène mélangé. Et pour
avoir juste le fer, il faut se
débarrasser de l'oxygène. C'est ça qu'on
appelle réduire un oxyde, c'est enlever
l'oxygène. Et pour ça, on a besoin
d'attaquer la molécule d'oxyde de fer
avec un truc un peu agressif euh qui va
enlever l'oxygène. Alors, jusqu'à
maintenant, le truc un peu agressif,
c'est du charbon pur, du coq, du du
masculin. Et donc, le charbon du coq va
bouffer l'oxygène qui ça se se marie
avec l'oxygène qui a dans la molécule,
le retire, l'arrache et laisse le faire
tout seul. Voilà. Et donc en bas du haut
fourneau, on a mis du minerais de fer et
du coque, on se retrouve avec du fer.
Bon, avec quelques impuretés s'appelle
de la fonte. Et donc le une autre
manière d'arracher la molécule
d'oxygène, enfin le l'atome d'oxygène à
la molécule d'oxyde de fer, c'est de le
faire avec de l'hydrogène. Et à ce
moment, on obtient de la vapeur d'eau
qui ne n'a pas d'impact sur le climat.
Donc pour ça, faut produire des
quantités d'hydrogène significatives.
Absolument. Euh donc il faut faire deux
choses. Il faut que la Sier investisse
de son côté dans un dispositif qui n'a
rien à voir avec un haut fourneau. Et de
l'autre côté, il faut évidemment que la
puissance publique mette de
l'électricité décarbonée en grande
quantité pour être capable de faire de
l'hydrogène. Ni l'un ni l'autre ne
dépend de quoi que ce soit fait ailleurs
dans le monde. Tout ça est à d'autres
mains. D'accord. Donc c'est voilà. Donc
c'est c'est ça qu'on a c'était ça le
cahier des charges qu'on a donné au
concepteur du plan.
c'était on va proposer des mesures qui
sont à notre main et je vais en donner
une dernière dans le transport aérien.
Ça fait 30 ans que les gens disent
"Comment est-ce qu'on peut faire pour le
modérer ? Faut taxer le kérose." Sauf
que taxer le kérosène, on peut pas.
Nous, on a trouvé un truc qui est
beaucoup plus simple,
c'est de limiter le nombre de créaux de
décollage. Ça c'est un autre main.
Et on avait rajouté que il y aurait
autant d'atterrissage qu'il voudrait.
On est on est sympa.
Voilà. Donc c'est c'est j'insiste
Français
des gens sur place.
Voilà.
Donc français donc français c'est
français parce
on par du volet immigration parou c'est
français parce que à notre main euh
après euh là où on est aussi résolument
optimiste et donc malgré notre drage de
boomer de temps en temps on est très
jeune d'esprit euh on est intimement
persuadé que si on a été capable
d'exporter la TVA le système métrique et
la délégation de service public si on a
la bonne gouvernance de ce genre de truc
et le bon plan de bataille ça
s'exportera aussi et donc ça nous ça
nous ramènera pardon d'utiliser ce
langage financier des dividendes
derrière C'estàd que on en aura le
bénéfice. Donc on a tout intérêt et de
toute façon les les grandes exportations
ont toujours commencé par un marché
domestique fort. Donc commençons par
faire les choses c'est nous. N'attendons
pas Dieu sait quel miracle de Dieu c'est
où. Et à notre et de notre point de vue,
c'est notre meilleure chance non
seulement d'avancer nous mais de donner
des bonnes idées aux autres.
Pour résumer trivialement la chose c'est
tout le monde veut planter des arbres
pour se mettre à l'ombre. Il faut bien
commencer c'est ça ?
Oui. Oui, il faut bien commencer. Ou
sinon sinon tout le monde veut se mettre
à l'ombre mais personne veut planter. Il
y a il y a il y a 15 ans au moment du
début du chiffre project, on avait
démarré un projet un peu farfelu aussi
qui était est-ce qu'on pourrait réécrire
la Constitution européenne
à à l'heure du monde fini ?
Est-ce qu'on pourrait faire tenir c'est
quoi le projet européen en 10 ou 15
alinéa ? Voilà, on avait embarqué Bris
Laonde là-dedans. C'était c'était un
projet assez marrant. Bon, il y a
finalement on a on avait pas les on
avait pas le muscle à l'époque pour
porter un truc comme ça. Euh mais euh je
je vous raconte cette anecdote parce que
à cette époque-là, j'avais été voir
Michel Rocard. C'est la seule fois de ma
vie, du reste où je l'ai où je l'ai vu.
Absolument. P à son â
d'ailleurs très très sensibilisé sur les
questions énergétiques.
Absolument. très question très et
j'avais trouvé le bonhomme par ailleurs
assez détonnant dans le pour un
responsable politique caractéristique
pas pas courante et alors il m'avait dit
en rigolant en voyant ce projet il
m'avait dit vous en avez pour 20 ans
mais vous avez bien raison faut bien
commencer un jour
oui je reprends le le l'argument de
Jean-Marc sur la faisabilité de ce plan
encore une fois on ne s'adresse que
enfin onadresse que des points qui sont
à la main de la politique locale. Je
reprends l'exemple de la mobilité. Il
appartient au maire d'une ville de
décider quel type de véhicule il est
centré dans la ville. Ça dépend pas
d'une réglementation extérieure ou donc
voilà, on peut pas s'abriter derrière
des d'autres raisons de ne pas faire. Si
on décide de baisser la vitesse maximale
des véhicules à 80 km/h pour la raison
de de protéger le climat, et bien on
peut le faire. On ne dépend de personne.
L'aspect social, il a été traité quand
même parce que faire euh rentrer des
véhicules dans sa ville et faire un
ghetto de riche qui peut s'acheter des
voitures électriques, c'est très bien.
Mais les petites mains euh roulent au
diesel avec des caisses qui ont plus de
15 ans. Euh vous avez traité un petit
peu ce point-là ? Alors, sur ce
point-là, euh un petit mot sur le
véhicule électrique versus le véhicule
thermique parce que
il faut fondamentalement la voiture
électrique, je un petit scoop, va être
beaucoup moins cher que le véhicule
thermique
parce que les taxes vont
non parce que il faut 10 he pour monter
une voiture électrique, il en faut 40
pour monter une voiture thermique. Il y
a pas plus de matière dans l'une que
dans l'autre. C'est beaucoup plus simple
avec
matières différentes.
C'est des matières différentes mais en
terme de temps de travail
en terme d'industrie, en terme de
d'exploitation minérale minière,
c'est un peu plus lourd mais en terme
d'industrie humaine moins de temps, donc
c'est moins de valeur. Donc tôt
aujourd'hui la voiture thermique elle
est moins chère. Pourquoi ? parce que
les constructeurs actuels ont des usines
et donc la production d'une voiture
thermique, c'est un coût marginal par
rapport à une usine qui existe qui est
déjà rentabilisée. Alors que le monde
électrique, le monde du véhicule
électrique, il est juste naissant. Donc
le coût individuel d'une de chaque
nouveau véhicule est plus élevé.
Ça va très rapidement s'inverser.
D'autre part, le c'est pas c'est pas ce
que dit un certain leader de l'industrie
automobile qui dit passer à tout
électrique va ça va créer des problèmes
socials.
Ah bah ça va lui ça va probablement lui
créer des problèmes socials. Mais ça
c'est chaque comme le disait Jean-Marc
tout à l'heure
bah parce que il faut transformer toute
sa propre industrie et toute sa propre
organisation elle est à transformer.
C'est un gros challenge. C'est-à-dire
que on a des équipes très importantes
qui sont capables de concevoir des des
moteurs thermiques qui fabriquent des
boîtes de vitesse.
Il y a des dizaines de milliers de gens
en France qui fabriquent des boîtes de
vitesse. Bon, ces gens-là, il faut
absolument qu'on réfléchisse
collectivement dans le cadre d'un plan à
ce vers quoi on va les orienter. Sinon,
assez rapidement, ils auront plus de
travail. Alors, quand j'entends euh vers
quoi on va les orienter,
c'est qu'il y en a certains qui vont se
retrouver sur le carreau
et qu'il faut un petit peu les pousser
un petit peu comme Maou, les mettre dans
les champs. C'est ça.
Je sais pas s'il y en aura jusque là. Ce
qui est sûr, non mais ce qui est
certain, c'est que on Mais c'est
vous avez raison. Mais ce qui est sûr,
c'est que si on n pas de plan, ils vont
se retrouver entre deux eau. Voilà
pourquoi il nous faut un plan. Il nous
faut un plan pour ça parce qu'on peut
pas juste attendre que les que les gars
déboulent dans la cour de la préfecture
et mettent des pneus en feu pour dire
"Ah oui, il y avait un problème, on n'y
avait pas réfléchi."
C'est un petit peu le light motif de nos
politiques ces dernières années. Ils
sont pas très proactifs.
Non.
Alors, je reprends le micro. Euh donc,
vous avez été vous avez évolué et nagé
avec les politiques pour leur faire
passer vos idées. Euh non, pas du tout.
cette hisire
non mais cette histoire de planification
on l'a on l'a on a essayé de la vendre
depuis 4 5 ans. Voilà et on nous a dit
oui oui c'est une bonne idée. Voilà mais
fais pas trop de bruit reste à ta place.
Voilà et bon on a dit
laisse les grands fers.
Non même pas c'est il voit pas le sujet.
Il voit le il voit pas le sujet. C'est
c'est
pourquoi il voit pas le sujet ?
Ça c'est la bonne question mais il voit
il voit il voit pas le sujet. Pour en
revenir à la question de l'emploi euh
est-ce que Laurent a fini ? Oui, je
reviendrai.
Euh, on est parfaitement conscient
depuis le début, depuis la première
minute où on a commencé à travailler à
ça, que l'emploi était un truc
absolument crucial qu'il fallait qu'on
traite dans ce plan. Donc, il y a un
chapitre du PTEF, du livre là qui porte
spécifiquement sur l'emploi.
Euh, il y a quoi ? C'est il faut que je
le montre, c'est ça ? Hop, hop. Voilà.
11,90 € pas cher.
Un plan pas cher France.
Un plan pas cher. Made in France.
Absolument. Euh et euh si je peux faire
une petite incise là-dessus,
mais avec l'accent Pier Pierre Bart
euh va être compliqué. Je je je
0,95.
Non, c'était juste pour dire au moment
où on a négocié avec Odil Jacob le fait
de faire ce livre, à titre personnel, je
me disais bon, il faut faire ce livre
parce que le
jeux dire parce que c'est quelque chose
qui va avoir de la de la valeur pour
tous les gens qui nous ont donné de
l'argent pour qu'on fasse le le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
parce qu'on a eu un financement
participatif important qui nous a permis
de faire ce travail sans lequel on
l'aurait jamais fait.
Et euh donc on a dit dans ce qu'on doit
aux gens qui nous ont financé, on va
leur donner une trace écrite condensée
du travail qu'ils ont permis de
financer. Euh et puis on s'est dit bon
bah du coup on va le vendre ce livre. Et
euh moi je me suis dit bon un ouvrage
collectif en général ça intéresse jamais
personne. Les éditeurs ont de ça du rest
absolument tenu à coller mon nom sur la
couverture parce que juste un truc
collectif ça. Et je me suis dit bon on
va en vendre 5000.
On a on est à 35000 de tirage. En 10
jours, on en a vendu 15000 ce qui pour
un ouvrage c'est juste hallucinant. Je
veux dire moi les essais que j'ai fait
dans ma vie, je pars des essais hein, il
y en a pas un qui en broché fait 20000
donc ils étaient tous un peu en dessous
et là il va finir à 50. Donc c'est juste
pour dire euh c'est très impressionnant.
Euh enfin moi je suis premier
impressionné et je pense que ça veut
dire qu'il y a une vraie appétance
derrière. Ça ça il se passe quelque
chose quoi. C'est pas c'est pas voilà.
Fin de la parenthèse. Donc pour en
revenir au chapitre emploi euh on a
on a on a on avait bien ça en tête dès
le début.
Et du coup, on a fait deux choses. La
première qu'on a fait, c'est qu'on a
fait un calcul qu'on a voulu honnête sur
de combien de personnes on aurait besoin
dans les secteurs qui sont favorisés par
la transition. Par exemple,
l'agriculture, par exemple le vélo, par
exemple la rénovation du logement et de
combien d'emplois on aurait plus besoin
dans un certain nombre de secteurs qui
eux vont se contracter, la fabrication
automobile ou la construction de
logement neuf. donc on et donc on a fait
plus moins. Alors à ce stade, on n pas
fait plus moins à nouveau en se disant
est-ce qu'il y aura l'argent pour les
payer ? On a pris un truc purement
physique. Par exemple pour rénover un
logement, il faut tant d'heures de
travail. Une personne travaille en tant
d'heures dans la semaine, il nous faut
autant de personnes. Et voilà. Et encore
une fois, à ce stade, on s'est pas posé
la question. Donc ça c'est un autre
angle mort, c'est que
quel type de charge, quel type de
fiscalité ? On on n' pas on n'a pas
regardé ça. On s'est dit d'abord on
essaie de décrire l'orientation générale
euh qu'il faut avoir. Si si je me
permettre de me prendre un parallèle un
peu martial et militaire. Euh quand on
part en guerre, on se demande de combien
de char et d'avion on a besoin et
ensuite seulement on se demande combien
on va lever d'impôts pour y arriver.
Mais on fait bien ça dans cet ordre-là.
On fait pas ça dans l'autre sens en
général. Ou combien de gens on a qui
sont capables de se battre et c'est
purement physique. Voilà. Donc là c'est
exactement pareil. Donc évidemment, on
part pas en guerre mais la première
chose qu'on est qu'on Oui oui. Non non,
on part pas en guerre, on part dans
l'action. Un peu différent. Mais la
première chose,
c'est pas un peu trop petit bras ?
Est-ce qu'il faut pas faire passer à la
population que si on se retrouve pas les
manches, parce que votre illustration
elle est très sympa. Si on se retrouve
pas les manches maintenant, on va
tellement déguster que on pourra même
plus agir.
Alors ça fait 15 ans que je passe ma vie
à ça et ça marche moyen. Dis autrement
quelque chose que j'ai fini par
comprendre. J'ai un peu l à la
comprenette euh c'est que si on se
contente de faire peur aux gens, ça
suffit pas. Euh une fois qu'on leur a
fait peur, il faut leur donner envie de
quelque chose. Donc encore une fois, je
suis un peu là à la comprenait. Donc
c'est un peu comme le bétail,
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut leur faire peur
avec un beau gros bruit et leur dire
"C'est par là que ça se passe."
Je sais bien qu'un homme célèbre a dit
que les français étaient dévau mais euh
comment il s'appelait déjà ?
Mais euh le
Mais en l'occurrence là, on prend pas
les gens pour du bétail. On on essaie de
leur proposer une construction qui nous
semble avoir sa pertinence. Et pour
revenir à la question de l'emploi, on a
depuis le début
souhaité discuter avec les organisations
syndicales pour leur exposer ce truc-là
et leur dire allez-y réfutez enfin
allez-y dites-nous ce qui vous plaît, ce
qui vous plaît pas et cetera. et et
notre à ma grande surprise parce que
personnellement je pensais qu'on allait
vraiment se faire accueillir avec des
tomates pourries. Euh
il y a une il y a une envie de discuter
avec cette forme ou avec cette entrée en
matière, on va dire qu'on a trouvé assez
forte et il y a de l'intérêt, il y a
beaucoup d'intérêt et on
ça comment dire ça ne les ennuie pas
qu'on leur dise vous savez la transition
ça va nous demander de gros efforts. il
va y avoir d'énormes sujets emploi et il
faut vraiment s'en occuper et les
anticiper. Et quand on leur dit ça, ils
nous disent pas du tout s'il doit y
avoir des sujet emploi, on veut même pas
en parler. Disent oui, non, c'est
intéressant. Discutons.
Ouais. Quand on a travaillé par exemple
pour le secteur de l'aérien, on a une
première réaction un peu mitigée de de
l'industrie aéronautique qui avait pas
tout compris ce qu'on voulait dire.
Donc on s'est faitpiller. Mais alors
mais juste après, on a eu une vague
incroyable de jeunes de l'industrie
aéronautique qui ont dit "Mais attendez,
mais nous c'est l'industrie qu'on veut
pour nous. On adore notre industrie
aéronautique et nous on a besoin de ce
planl parce que c'est ça qu'on veut
faire nous." Voilà. Donc voilà, quand on
parce que il les g les gens se
projettent dans un modèle industriel
raisonnable. Voilà. Et donc le plan, ça
sert à ça. Ça sert à donner envie. Ça
sert à donner envie.
Revenons à nos leaders d'opinion les
politiques. Donc
vous avez dit deux choses différentes là
entre leader et opinion.
Vous avez dit
leader d'opinion et politique.
Bah ils sont censés être leader
d'opinion. Non
je sais pas c'est vous qui le dites.
Non mais c'est une très bonne remarque
que vous dites que c'est vous faites
l'avocat du diable à ma place. C'est
donc je vous laisse continuer.
Non, mais je pense que
l'opinion enfin en tout cas sur ce sujet
de la transition, il y a d'abord une
énorme envie des gens de ce pays. La
convention citoyenne, on peut dire ce
qu'on veut mais elle a exprimé une envie
d'un nombre de gens, de citoyens qu'on
est allé chercher au hasard.
Faire l'avocat du diable.
Allez-y.
C'est combien de personnes ? C'est un
Pem. Attends, c'est un PEM.
Quand on prend quand on prend le pardon,
peu importe, c'est un pouillet mais ils
étaient tous passionnés. Au bout de
trois weekends, ils voulaient plus en
sortir, hein. C'est-à-dire que
les gens marquent, c'est pour ça
que
non, pas du tout,
pas du tout. Et en fait, ils reviennent
nous voir en disant "Mais mais nous on n
pas eu le temps, on n pas eu le temps,
on est frustré. Est-ce que vous faites
le plan ? Ça nous passionne ?" Parce que
une fois qu'on est rentré dans vous
connaissez ce point, une fois qu'on est
rentré là-dedans, on n'en sort plus
jamais hein. C'est un pu de potentiel le
sujet du climat. Bon, bref, je dire que
les gens,
on peut résumer ça différemment. C'est
heureux les simples d'esprit.
Voilà. Mais bon, disons qu'en tout cas
euh
il y a une envie de comprendre pour ceux
qui ont commencer et une fois qu'on a
commencé, qu'on a tiré le fil, ça vous
savez quelque chose, on sort plus jamais
de ce problème. Voilà, de ce sujet. Et
il y a de plus en plus de citoyens de ce
pays dont l'opinion c'est qu'il faut
faire quelque chose, dont l'opinion
c'est qu'il faut un plan. Voilà. Donc
les politiques, moi je pense qu'ils ont
un très noble métier, mais leur métier
c'est de Oui, c'est un métier, c'est un
c'est une vocation, c'est dur.
Tri.
Peut-être c'est un métier, c'est une
vraie vocation. Moi, j'en connais pas
mal. Il y en a qui il y en a qui se
bagarent
local
local nationaux et
des noms il y en a que c'est les mêmes
que vous mais non mais des des gens mais
dans toutes les corporations, il y a des
gens bien, il y a des il y a des
passionnés, il y a voilà et cetera puis
il y a des il y a des foireux. Bon mais
quand même ces gens-là leur métier ou
faut leur vocation c'est aussi de
du pognon.
Non pas vraiment.
Mais le leur vocation c'est d'exprimer,
c'est c'est de porter le c'est de porter
les envies de la population qu'il
représente. Donc l'opinion euh
il faut que la il faut retourner la
population, il faut chifter la
population pour chifter nos politiques.
Oui.
D'accord. Moi, je vais vous poser une
autre question concernant les leaders
d'opinion. Jean-Marc, tu veux vous
voulez ajouter quelque chose ? Euh oui,
non, c'était euh tout à l'heure, vous
avez dit vous parlez aux politiques,
c'était dans la dans la même veine hein.
En fait, avec le plan de transformation
de l'économie française, on veut pas
d'abord parler aux politiques, on veut
d'abord parler aux électeurs
et aux gens qui les représentent. Donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a tellement envie de
discuter avec les syndicats, avec le
patronat, euh avec le monde académique,
avec des élus locaux parce que dans le
monde politique en fait, là c'est
pareil, j'ai mis un certain temps à
comprendre mais c'est très très
différent. Non, mais en terme de euh
type de comportement, de réflexe,
peut-être de sérieux aussi, il y a une
grosse grosse différence entre les élus
locaux et les élus nationaux. Euh en
gros, plus on est près du pouvoir
central euh et plus on a un comportement
d'exécuteur testamentaire, euh quand on
est plus près du terrain, on a un un
Ouais. Enfin, le le les réflexes sont
pas exactement les mêmes. D'abord, la
longévité est pas exactement la même. Et
ce
direct lecteur est à ta porte quand
même.
Oui, il y en a beaucoup. Bon, alors
après, il peut il y a à boire et à
manger, hein. Je suis pas en train de
dire que les élus locaux sont
formidables, mais il ils font pas
exactement le même métier, on va dire.
Mais dans tous les cas de figure, nous
ce qui nous intéresse, c'est pas de
parler aux politiques parce que là c'est
pareil, enfin moi à titre personnel,
j'en suis revenu euh quand j'étais jeune
et naïf, c'est-à-dire jusqu'à il y a 2
ans, non je euh je il m'arrivait de me
dire "Bon, politique, c'est les gens
comme moi, donc je vais aller les voir,
je vais leur expliquer en quoi ça serait
dans leur intérêt ou et cetera de faire
telle ou telle chose."
En plus, c'est très désorientant parce
que quand on est face à face, il vous
parle comme si vous étiez quelqu'un de
normal et eux-mêmes se comportent comme
s'ils étaient quelqu'un de normal. Et ça
les empêche absolument pas face caméra
le lendemain de dire l'exacte inverse de
ce qu'ils vous ont raconté avec la foie
du charbonnier. Donc c'est très
désorientant au début et puis j'ai fini
par comprendre que si on parle des élus
nationaux c'est vraiment alors cette
expression est peut-être un peu méchante
mais pas très loin de la vérité pour
moi. C'est des exécuteurs
testamentaires. Donc en fait il faut
parler aux gens qui font le testament
c'est-à-dire à leurs électeurs. Donc il
faut aller voir les électeurs. qu'en
fait dans le dans le road show pardon
d'utiliser un mot anglais de de notre
plan de transformation de l'économie
française, on n' pas prévu d'aller voir
de politique et ce qui est farce c'est
que du coup de temps en temps, il y en a
un qui se manifeste en disant tiens, on
aimerait bien vous voir. Euh
de votre aura,
je sais pas ce qu'ils veulent exactement
mais de toute façon là c'est pareil
maintenant j'ai fini par comprendre. En
fait le politique faut lui parler quand
il a besoin de vous. Tant qu'il a pas
besoin de vous, c'est pas la peine de
lui parler. Donc et il aura besoin de
nous, enfin il aura besoin de nous
parler plus exactement
si euh ce travail trouve une résonance
suffisante
auprès des gens qui votent. Voilà. Donc
c'est vraiment ça, c'est vraiment ça
notre cible, c'est aller voir euh encore
une fois les gens qui font la société
euh et si et si ça marche, si on est
crédible, si les gens disent "Oui, on a
envie de raisonner de cette manière, on
a envie de de vous aider ou d'aider
parce que nous, pas nous en particulier,
Laurent et moi on s'en fout, on est
rien." Euh mais d'aider à cette démarche
qui est construire ensemble un truc qui
fasse un peu consensus et qui donne une
direction qui s'appelle un plan. À ce
moment, le politique embriera.
Oui, d'ailleurs les il y a les
politiques vis-à-vis des des idées qu'on
manipule n'ont aucun caractère
caractéristique de le de l' de leur
origine politique. C'estàd qu'ils ont
tous les mêmes réactions positives ou
négatives par rapport indépendamment
il convulse un peu ou pas du tout ?
Comment dites-vous ?
Ils convulsent.
Non, ils sont un peu ils sont un peu squ
quand même. Oui.
En mode catatonie émotionnel. En mode
quoi ? en mode euh ah oui, il y a quand
même beaucoup de travail et en mode euh
mais moi j'ai pas les moyens de faire
tout ce travail de recherche là. Il me
dit "Je vous envie". J'ai entendu ça
hein. Par qui ?
Par des politiques connus que non mais
disant "Mais moi j'ai pas les capacités
de recherche que vous avez. Je peux pas
instruire les de Oui, donc il était avec
sa personne qui était en charge des
contenus. J'ai une personne en charge
des contenus. Bon,
écrivez-moi un petit mail.
Voilà. Mais donc c'est intéressant parce
qu' ils reconnaissent que il y a
beaucoup de travail pour instruire ce
sujet. Voilà. Et donc on la plupart
d'entre eux sont quand même assez
intéressés parce que ces contenus là ils
ont pas les moyens de les instruire
eux-mêmes. C'est un peu compliqué ce
qu'on fabrique et il y a beaucoup de
travail.
Donc voilà. Donc l'opinion ça se
fabrique comme le dit Jean-Marc avec le
plus grand nombre.
Alors alors j'ai pas entendu un mot qui
est intéressant.
Je voulais d'ailleurs en profiter j'ai
oublié en début d'émission. Je voulais
dédier cette émission à à mon ami
Jacques Blamont qui est décédé euh
récemment, qui est quelqu'un qui a écrit
un livre absolument extraordinaire qui
s'appelle Introduction au siècle des
menaces et un autre d'ailleurs qui
c'était qui était le le chiffre et le
songe.
Euh lui avait essayé à son époque de
contacter les leaders de religion
pour faire basculer les opinions
publiques. Et donc je vous pose la
question, est-ce que vous avez fait
commu en allant voir le cardinal noir ou
le pape euh ou le grand moufti ou je ce
que vous voulez. Est-ce que vous avez
contacté les meilleurs propagandistes
depuis ces 2000 dernières années pour
faire passer votre message en leur
disant "Écoutez-moi bien, vos ouailles
vont prendre quand même un gros coup de
chaud parce que les voix du Seigneur
sont quand même impénétrables et les
rayons du soleil ça risque de faire
quelques petites cloques. Est-ce que
vous avez contacté les religieux ?
Est-ce que les religieux ont aussi leur
cellule de prospective ou ils contentent
de faire perdurer ce petit rondron
quotidien ?
On est au début de notre processus de
vente si j'utilise ce terme. Euh le plan
de transformation de l'économiste, le
bouquin là, il est sorti il y a une
semaine. Euh le en fait, on n même pas
fini de produire des rapports complets
dans tous les secteurs qu'on couvre.
C'estàd que là, on a le on a le cadre,
on a le condensé mais le rapport
complet, il reste à venir dans un
certain nombre des enfin trois ou quatre
secteurs qu'on a pas encore euh fini
fini de travailler parce qu'on avait
décidé de de d'échelonner euh les
présentations des des secteurs. Là, le
bouquin fait 250 pages mais derrière il
y a 1500 pages de rapport donc un peu
plus de matière
inhabitable
un truc bien. Il est il était
intéressant pour comme l'a dit Laurent
tout à l'heure les gens avec lesquels
nous avons travaillé euh quand nous
avons réfléchi à ce qu'on pouvait faire.
Donc effectivement, c'est des rapports
sectoriels qui sont lus inextinens par
les gens du secteur qui veulent voir ce
qu'on a raconté dans leur secteur. C'est
il y a que on la motivation pour lire
les 100 pages en question. Les gens qui
s'intéressent à la démarche dans leur
ensemble, ils vont plutôt lire le résumé
exécutif qui fait trois pages euh et qui
est pas très très loin de des trois
pages ou des quatre pages par secteur
queon va retrouver dans le dans le
livre.
Euh donc aujourd'hui notre processus de
vente, j'ai envie de dire on le démarre,
notre processus de dialogue pour être
plus politiquement correct. Euh donc euh
avec qui on le démarre ? Donc j'ai dit
tout à l'heure avec la société civile.
Alors qui on va trouver dans la société
civile ? Effectivement, j'ai pas
mentionné euh les les dignitaires
religieux mais c'est à l'évidence des
des interlocuteurs intéressants. Euh
pour le moment, on n'a pas reçu de
sollicitation. Moi, j'ai pas de ligne
directe avec l'archevêque de Paris. Mais
par contre dans le passé, j'ai envie de
dire quand on quand j'ai reçu des
sollicitations de ce genre de
personnage, j'ai toujours essayé de
répondre oui. Euh parce que
effectivement c'est des gens qui ont qui
sont qui sont un liant euh pour une
partie importante de la population et
qui sont écoutés par une partie
importante de la population. Donc
dialoguer avec des gens comme ça, c'est
important. Oui.
Oui.
Vous vous avez des copains imaginaires
vous ou pas du tout ? Vous
Non,
la science a tué Dieu pour vous aussi ?
Non mais
oui. Non mais je pense qu'effectivement
c'est une c'est un c'est un relais de
d'opinion qu'il faut aussi qu'on
qu'on travaille très probablement.
Revenons à nos moutons. On va on va
commencer à se taper, on est d'accord.
Euh vous parlez de transformation,
ça va mettre des risques sur certains
business.
Des risques comment ? Dégradation de
notes d'une dette.
ça peut faire ça peut piquer quand même
un minimum euh certaines entreprises qui
risquent de se prendre des procès pour
une action climatique.
Ouais.
Donc cette déstabilisation euh
financière, est-ce que vous vous avez
bossé un peu dessus ? Je prends juste un
exemple.
Ouais.
Admettons qu' un fond censé payer la
retraite des fonctionnaires détenant x
volume d'action qui risque d'entreprises
qui risquent de se faire un petit peu
taper par la transition. Donc sa valeur
va descendre. Euh donc le rendement
qu'on avait promis au retraités au
fonctionnair risque de baisser ou est-ce
que le choc systémique sur l'économie a
été anticipé ?
Aujourd'hui non, il y a pas encore
d'effet massif de la perception du
risque climatique dans la valeur des
actifs. C'est pas encore massif, ça
existe.
C'est très naissant.
Il y a une partie des investisseurs qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet, mais ça reste
pas du tout, comme on dit, mainstream
aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui, ça reste
niche. On est au tout début de cette
perception que dans cette affaire de
transition, il y a des risques. Des
risques en finance, c'est aussi des
opportunités. Donc, il y a une
spéculation au sens
de la spéculation du futur.
Placer les risques, c'est une
opportunité.
C'est une opportunité pour faire quoi ?
Bah, pour gagner.
Pour faire du blé. Oui. Bon, non, mais
le rôle de la finance enfin avant
financer les entreprises,
non
non, c'est de faire
moi je pense pas non. Moi je pense
c'est de router les flux financiers.
Non,
c'est de brasser du vent.
Non, il y en a il y en a pour qui con
Moi, je pense que quand on quand on
regarde la financequelle, son sa
première miss enfin sa mission
cardinale,
c'est de
c'est de protéger le capital des gens
qui lui ont confié de l'argent. Quand
vous vous donnez de l'argent à votre
caisse de retraite, c'est pour espérer
que l'argent que vous mettez de côté
aujourd'hui, vous êtes un peu jeune
encore, vous pouvez encore croire à la à
la retraite, mais disons euh
capitalisation.
Oui. Par exemple, ou même bon, vous vous
mettez de l'argent de côté, vous espérez
qu'on va vous restituer dans quelques
années l'équivalent en argent de
en pouvoir d'achat. En gros,
donc la première mission de l'épargnant,
faut faut lire, c'est la protection du
capital.
C'est pour ça que massivement les gens
ils investissent d'abord dans des dettes
d'État parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
sûr pour discuter. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi
il pense que c'est sûr ?
Mais c'est la perception générale que la
dette d'État
Est-ce que les dates d'État sont sûres ?
Je suis je suis pas assez spéculateur
pour discuter de ça, mais en tout cas en
terme de comportement en terme de
comportement des épargnants, vous
reconnaîtrez avec moi que le premier
réflexe, c'est de c'est d'investir dans
du de la dette d'État, ensuite dans
l'immobilier et ensuite éventuellement
en action d'entreprise. Donc c'est bien
la recherche de la sûreté du capital qui
est moteur dans l'épargne, hein. Et donc
dans notre affaire avant de
avant de de s'occuper du rendement,
l'investisseur, il s'occupe surtout de
prendre le moins de risque possible.
Donc effectivement, vous avez raison, la
finance, on si elle est intelligente par
rapport à ce sujet, si elle est
intelligente par rapport à ce sujet,
elle va se préoccuper des risques avant
de s'occuper du rendement et donc elle
va essayer de regarder dans cette
affaire de transition ou pas mettre les
pieds pour pas se faire attraper par les
strandidass et les transitions brutales.
Donc revenons un petit peu sur les
transitions brutales. Euh revenons sur
la crise des subprimes.
Ouais. Revenons sur les agences de
notation. H
revenons sur le fait que la Chine et la
Russie ont créé leur propre agence de
notation. Est-ce qu'il y a un aspect
politique dans les agences de notation ?
Et est-ce qu' on va
Non, non, mais je j'attends la fin de la
question.
Est-ce que Est-ce qu'on va pas se
retrouver avec certains intérêts qui
vont un petit peu freiner des cas de fer
parce que ils savent que pour leur
business, c'est pas bon du tout et ils
savent qu'ils vont pas pouvoir fournir
derrière les promesses de rendement
qu'ils ont.
Alors les gens de notation c'est pas
politique, c'est mercantil.
C'est surtout politique. Non
c'est non c'est des business, c'est des
c'est des gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent. C'est des entreprises qui
vendent de la notation. C'est d'abord
mercantil faut jamais ils sont
ils sont un petit peu plantés sur les
man brothers ou des choses comme ça. Non
c'est oui oui. Et sur plein d'autres
sujets. Ils ont
Oh bah sur les dettes sur les dettes
souveraines. Bon il
très stable. C'est ça.
Quand il s'était planté sur la Grèce.
Voilà. Donc
il s'était planté pourquoi ? des raisons
politiques où ils avaient les yeux avec
des lunettes roses.
Alors les arges de notation, elles
fonctionnent de la manière suivante. En
fait, elle elles sont mercantil, elles
offrent le service qu'elles offrent, moi
c'est ma perception, elles offrent le
service de dire au plus grand nombre ce
qu'elles ce qu'elles savent du prix de
la dette. Elles constatent le prix de la
dette. Au fond, elles sont une espèce de
gigantesque agence de reporting du vrai
prix de la dette. La dette, la dette
elle se elle se négocie en permanence
entre les prêteurs et les emprunteurs.
Les de notation, elles ne fixe pas le
niveau de la dette. Elles enregistré,
ce que le l'opinion, ce que l'opinion
financier constate. C'est dans ce
sens-là que ça marche et il se rémunère
là-dessus. Donc c'est le thermomètre. Il
faut l'agence de 21 c'est le
thermomètre. Alors quelquefois il y en
comme dans toutes les entreprises, il y
en a qui dérapent puis le thermomètre se
met à déconner. Euh ça peut arriver hein
mais fondamentalement
elles ont pas d'intention. C'est société
commercial utilisé pour dire voilà bah
l'entreprise qui du de certains pays euh
c'est pas très bien. Donc ça permet de
faire baisser sa note
mais c'est un business, il s'en fout.
C'est un business. Faut
je vous pose une question concernant les
dettes. Est-ce que les agences de
notation ont mis des principes
d'évaluation de la du côté vert des
dettes ?
Alors c'est le début mais c'est vraiment
extrêmement modeste, extrêmement
parcellaire. euh très maladroit. On est
au tout début de cette perception que le
risque de transition va être un risque
financier. Et voilà, on est au tout
début.
Il y en a quelquesun risque de quelle
taille ? Un risque de quelle taille ?
Un risque euh bah
le Non, mais le fossile c'est c'est 80 %
de l'économie.
D'accord. Donc si on dit
mondial,
bah oui, donc si on dit que donc ça va
toucher 80 % de la valeur des choses,
même plus
et même plus. Ça va tout mais ça va tout
transformer, c'est évident.
Est-ce que Est-ce que j'ai je vais me
faire un peu l'avocat du diable ou
quand on se retrouve avec 80 % du bousin
Ouais.
qui risque d'impacter 80 % du bousin.
On n pas on n'est pas arrivé à un point
de non retour en terme de
transformation. Jean-Marc, je vois un
oui de la tête. Pourquoi ?
Bien sûr que si partiellement. Euh mais
on on s'en cache pas. C'est-à-dire, ça
renvoie à la première question de cet
échange. Qu'est-ce qu'on risque si on ne
fait rien ? C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on
risque ? Pensez qu'aujourd'hui à 8
milliards d'individus sur la planète en
ayant créé un système qui dépend d'une
ressource épuisable, euh on va pouvoir
en sortir
sans effort, sans heur et cetera. C'est
évidemment une illusion. C'est pas notre
promesse à nous. Nous, notre promesse,
c'est de ramener le maximum d'espoir
qu'on peut dans cette transformation et
c'est de ramener le maximum de prise sur
notre destin qu'on peut avoir dans un
bateau qui va quand même être un peu
secoué dans la tempête. Bon, donc notre
promesse, c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure, on parlait du politique. Euh on
on n'est pas en train de dire "Votez
pour nous" et vous aurez des jours
radieux. On est en train de dire euh
pour un parallèle qui vaut ce qui vaut,
on est dans un escape game et nous on a
un plan de sortie. Mais il va quand même
falloir transpirer.
Va
pouvoir tout sortir.
Faut l'espérer en tout cas. Il faut
faire en sorte que on peut pas, il y a
10 minutes, poser une question sur la
religion et dire 10 minutes après, bon,
on va on va considérer qu'on en
zigouille la moitié et l'autre moitié ça
ira bien. Donc non, mais voilà. Donc en
tout cas, à titre personnel, c'est pas
conforme à mes valeurs morales de dire
on va commencer par en zigouiller la
moitié parce que ça rendra la vie plus
facile à l'autre moitié. Par contre, le
vrai risque, c'est qu'on en arrive là.
Euh si on si si on se laisse aller, il
est là le vrai risque.
On disait qu'on seigouille la moitié
que ça finisse dans le bordel.
Ça fait ça fournit ça finiss ça finisse
dans le chaos et le et le chaos en
général c'est pas très bon pour
l'espérance de vie quoi.
Euh donc alors l'espérance de vie ou
voilà donc c'est donc donc pour donc la
la la la question de
est-ce que on va pouvoir encore une fois
transitionner sans effort pas une
seconde. Est-ce que ne pas s'organiser
va nous dispenser des efforts ? Pas une
seconde non plus.
pas une seconde.
Non, mais ça va permettre que les
efforts soient abonnéciants. Nous, ce
qu'on propose comme plan, tout le monde
sait qu'il va falloir faire des efforts
consciemment ou inconsciemment. Ce qu'on
propose, c'est quelque chose qui matche,
qui boucle. Voilà, c'est si on fait les
efforts dans ce sens-là, a priori ça
fonctionne. On résout l'équation de la
décarbonation de l'économie française.
Voilà. Donc ça vaut le coup de se
bagarrer pour un truc, on n pas sûr
qu'on va y arriver mais ça vaut le coup
de se bagarrer parce que à la fin on est
dans l'équation qu'on a recherché. On
on le voit bien si on se si on se défait
pas de combustible épuisable. Euh la
crise qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment sur les carburants et les gaz,
c'est la première d'une très longue
série et la très longue série sera bien
pire. Euh c'est indépendamment des
sujets des sujets climatiques. Donc on
va avoir une économie qui va être
secouée de plus en plus violemment.
Quand on secoue l'économie de plus en
plus violemment, il y a un moment où la
case sociale devient telle que le
système
le système implose parce que les gens se
sentent dépossédé de de le de de la
maîtrise de leur propre vie
le propre rêve.
Propre vie, propre rêve. Il broent du
noir, ils voi pas où ils vont, ils se
ils se ils se disent que ils ont pas
d'avenir, ils voient pas comment ils
vont faire, ils commencent à déprimer.
Enfin, tout ça n'est pas très bon quoi.
Ça fait le lit des de certains
religieux, non ? Oui, ça alors ça fait
le lit mais enfin je suis pas tellement
pressé que il s'empare du pouvoir.
Certains politiques.
Oui. Oui. Mais moi je suis je suis pas
je suis pas très pressé que je suis pas
très pressé que enfin j'ai pas d'action
chez ces gens-là. Donc je vois pas
pourquoi on aurait des propositions
qui conduisent à leur faciliter la vie.
Euh et inversement,
on en parlait tout à l'heure.
Une des choses qui aujourd'hui me
frappe,
alors peut-être que nous on est
excessivement, en tout cas moi je suis
excessivement angoissé, mais c'est une
forme de décalage qui peut y avoir entre
l'insouciance de la communication d'un
certain nombre de gens qui occupent
actuellement des fauteuils ministériels
et ce que nous on considère être
l'urgence de la situation et la vitesse
à laquelle il faut commencer à faire des
choses de de de de façon concrète pour
éviter de se prendre le mur. Euh il y a
Brudo Lemer qui a dit pas plus tard
qu'il y a quelques jours sur France
Interre que il avait pas idée que il
nous fallait autant d'électricité
décarboné.
C'est c'est c'est quand même le signe
que il y a un décalage important
entre le la la prise de conscience qu'on
ou que n'ont pas un certain nombre de
gens qui sont actuellement au pouvoir ou
qui ambitionnent d'y être parce que pas
toujours beaucoup mieux de l'autre côté.
Euh et euh ce que nous dit déjà
aujourd'hui une partie de la société
civile.
Laurent, vous avez chiffré à peu près
combien ça va nous coûter en terme de
pognon ou en terme de ressources en
kilow, en cobalt, en ce que vous voulez,
en route vélo.
Alors, on a chiffré Oui. En cobalt, en
route de vélo, en en quantité de cuivre,
en quantité de d'énergie,
crayon de combustible
en en matière, en ressources naturelles.
Oui,
on a compté et on a bouclé. Voilà. Donc
c'est c'est dans le document.
C'est combien ?
Bah vous
il y a une série de chiffres donc je
vais pas en sortir deux là.
Remarque.
Moi je les ai pas très honnêtement je
les ai pas de tête. Le cahier des
charges
100 milliards c'est ça.
Non on pas parler d'argent. On pas on n
jamais parlé d'argent et on en parlera
pas. Non.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ce qui nous importe
c'est les conditions nécessaires à la
transformation. les conditions
nécessaires à la transformation,
c'est que ça boucle en terme de
ressources parce qu'on a une ambition de
réduire nos émissions d'ici 2050. Il
faut qu'on y arrive et c'est les
ressources humaines. C'est comment on
fait pour que les gens leurs
compétences, leur savoir, le leurs
connaissances leur permettent de faire
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
transformation dans l'économie et il
faut apprendre à faire de nouveaux
métiers. Voilà. Donc ça, on a mesuré
l'argent l'argent il viendra au secours
de cette transformation. L'argent c'est
une convention à un moment donné où des
gens qui savent faire quelque chose
vendent leur service à d'autres gens qui
en ont besoin. Ce trucl ça s'ajustera.
Ça s'est toujours ajusté dans l'histoire
du monde et oui, à la marge, il faut un
petit peu de politique publique qui va
aider ici, retirer là, taxer par ici en
accompagnement, mais c'est jamais la
condition première de la transformation.
Alors, vous parlez de taxer. Alors,
taxer, ça veut dire quoi ? On va vous
prendre beaucoup et vous allez avoir à
peu près deux fois moins de votre niveau
de vie. Ça veut dire taxer pour reuter
les flux financiers. Ça veut dire quota
énergétique. Attendez, j'ai pas fini.
Est-ce que vous avez bossé sur l'évasion
fiscale parce que taxer c'est bien beau
parce que l'évasion fiscale ça n'a pas
de frontière.
Oui.
Donc vous avez pas bossé sur le
l'évasion fis. pasé sur on avait déjà
assez à faire avec les matières et et
les ressources humaines et on n'est pas
expert de la problématique de l'évasion
fiscale. Jean-Marc
Non non non, on n pas en fait on a même
pas travaillé du tout sur la fiscalité à
ce stade. On en est reste. U fiscalité
coercitive.
C'est pas c'est pas ça le sujet. Euh ce
qu' ce qu'a dit euh ce qu'a dit Laurent
c'est que on part de du projet et
derrière on regarde ce que ça veut dire
si on veut mettre en en œuvre ce projet.
qui paye qui, avec quel argent, sorti
d'où ? Mais encore une fois, il faut
bien se rappeler que l'argent est une
convention. Euh c'est juste une
convention. Le jour où les hommes
disparaîtront, il y aura plus d'argent.
Euh alors que par contre, il y aura
toujours du cuivre et toujours euh donc
le ce qu'on ce qu'on a Oui. Donc ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a vraiment cherché à
faire, c'est de partir du début. Encore
une fois, tout à l'heure, on la question
était "Est-ce qu'il y a des angles morts
au sens de est-ce qu'il y a des tr
sujets qu'on a pas encore traité Oui,
c'est c'est on est au début de
l'histoire, je le répète, il a fallu
deux siècles pour perfectionner le
système fossile. Euh nous, on en est à 2
ans avec quelques centaines de personnes
pour voir comment on détricote
intelligemment. C'est évident qu'on a
pas tout couvert partout et tout le
temps. C'est
bien ce que vous avez fait. Non,
merci.
Je rigole pas trop parce que j'arrive.
En terme en terme de
vitesse, en terme de vélocité,
on a combien de temps ? Il nous reste
combien de temps pour éviter que ça
parte en sucette ?
Hier,
ça dépend de quoi on parle.
Il y a des coups parties dans le système
physique pour lesquels maintenant ils
sont partis. Ils sont partis. Alors, je
vais donner un exemple qui est la fond
la fonte du Groenland.
La calotte grenlandaise a commencé à
fondre et la manière dont se déroule le
processus fait que maintenant on peut
plus l'arrêter. D'accord ? Même si on
arrête les émissions demain matin, on
peut plus l'arrêter.
Ça ça veut dire à l'échelle de quelques
siècles. Al quelques siècles c'est long,
d'accord, mais le coût est parti. Ça
veut dire que il va y avoir 3 à 6 m
d'eau en plus dans l'océan mondial.
3 à 6 m d'eau en plus, ça veut dire que
les infrastructures portuaires partout
dans le monde sont hors service. Bon ou
en tout cas plus de Bangladesh.
Euh il y a plus de Bangladesh. Voilà.
Donc voilà un exemple de coup parti dans
le monde physique. Donc combien de temps
il nous reste pour éviter ça ? Bah il
nous reste moins quelque chose puisque
c'est déjà parti. Donc on va on va quoi
qu'il arrive se taper des flux
migratoires parce que
on va se taper l'acid la salénisation
des sols qui était un peu plus loin.
Exactement. Donc il y a des
ça c'est acté
c'est acté. Il y a des choses pour
lesquelles le le coup est parti. Même si
l'élévation de température s'arrêtait
demain matin, il y a aussi des
conséquences écosystémiques qui vont
mettre du temps à arriver. Alors je vais
prendre un autre exemple que les gens
connaissent bien dans ce pays qui est le
dépérissement d'un certain nombre
d'espèces d'arbres. Euh là à 1,1 ou 1,2°
d'élévation de la température
planétaire, même si on s'arrête demain
matin, il y aura de plus en plus
d'épicéas qui vont mourir euh dans les
dans l'est. Il y aura de plus en plus de
êtres qui vont mourir dans un certain
nombre de régions françaises, chaînes
pédonculées qui vont et cetera. Donc il
y a il y a un certain nombre de la
sécheresse des sols va s'intensifier euh
dans un certain nombre d'endroits parce
que le déficit hydrique quand il est
répété tous les ans, bah à un moment ça
finit par en finit par en voir la
conséquence. Donc il y a un certain
nombre de coûts parties maintenant on
peut juste plus les éviter. Quoi qu'on
fasse, nous ce qu'on dit c'est pas la
promesse qu'on fait c'est pas de
remettre le système en l'état si peut
pas. Bon par contre la promesse qu'on
fait encore une fois c'est de faire le
maximum pour se mettre dans une
situation dans laquelle notre destin
reste au mieux maîtrisable. Sachant
qu'il y aura quand même des aléas, il va
quand même y avoir des flux migratoires,
euh il va quand même y avoir euh oui, on
va quand même se prendre des claques,
c'est absolvité, c'est juste voilà. Mais
euh
ça vaut ce que ça vaut, mais euh quand
on a fumé pendant 20 ans, euh bah euh
c'est quand même ça reste quand même une
bonne idée de s'arrêter de fumer. Euh
c'était mieux de pas commencer mais ça
reste quand même une bonne idée de
s'arrêter. Et bien c'est exactement
pareil là, à quelques moments qu'on
passe à l'action, de toute façon, c'est
un arbitrage qui nous est favorable à à
quelques moments qu'on décide de passer.
Voilà. Et plus on y passe tôt et plus ça
nous est favorable. Donc là, on a déjà
perdu du temps d'une certaine manière et
donc nous ce qu'on dit c'est il faut s'y
mettre demain matin. Raison pour
laquelle dans ce plan, on ne propose pas
des objectifs à 2050 point bar, on
propose des objectifs à 2027 et on
propose même des objectifs à on va même
réfléchir à des objectifs à 2022,
c'est-à-dire des trucs pour lesquels euh
là on n pas encore fait mais c'est une
de mes envies. Donc j'espère que je vais
pas faire une promesse de Gascon. Euh
mais c'estque
ou de ou de politique, ce qui est
parfois pareil, euh qui est de réfléchir
aux mesures des 100 premier jours,
c'est-à-dire en gros quelqu'un qui
dirait "Votre travail là c'est pas
idiot" et qui deviendrait le nouveau
locataire de l'Élysée euh ou la
répétition de l'ancien. S'il est en
phase avec ce qu'on propose, quelles
sont les mesures des 100 premiers jours
qu'il doit absolument prendre ? Sinon ça
veut dire qu'en fait il est pas d'accord
avec nous.
Ouais, il y a quand même une forme
d'urgence à agir aussi parce qu'on est,
on va dire, encore dans un système
démocratique qui fonctionne et qui
fonctionne.
C'est très bien ce que je
pas si mal. C'est-à-dire que l'urgence
qu'on a nous, c'est dire voilà, on est
quand même encore un pays assez riche.
Enfin, il y a bien sûr des gens qui
souffrent dans notre pays, enfin qui
sont pas au niveau où ils devraient
être, c'est objectif. Mais globalement,
on a encore les moyens d'action dans ce
pays-là. On n'est pas on n'est pas à
l'ose. On a des on a des latitudes, on a
des marges de manœuvre.
Je peux vous contredire ? Je vais
prendre les mots d'un grand penseur
philosophique français.
Alors là,
François Fillon, je suis
Ah d'accord. Bon,
je suis premier ministre d'un état en
faillite.
Oui, mais
on a des démarches de l'attitude avec la
dette, on a démargitude avec
l'exploitation minière,
on a démarg de l'attitude avec la
stabilité sociale.
On a démargitude en terme de
d'encadrement de la finance.
On a démarche de l'attitude comment là
on a encore
parce que là quand quand j'écoute
François
mais on l'écoute plus beaucoup, on
l'entend plus beaucoup.
J'ai l'impression qu'on est quand même
en short en tong sans crème solaire et
en en plein désert quand même. Non
en plein hiver. Ouais.
Non en plein désert parce que l'hiver on
sent pas la douleur tout de suite.
Ouais mais oui. Écoutez, je connais pas
bien la philosophie de du penseur dont
vous parlez. Euh enfin en détail.
Vous avez pas voté pour lui ?
Euh bah non. Euh
pour son collègue,
je me souviens plus. Mais c'est
qui avait les petites talonnettes là.
Oui, je me souviens plus trop. Euh en
tout cas, ce qui est sûr, vous
votez quelle tendance sans indiscrétion
?
Bah moi, j'ai voté la dernière fois j'ai
voté Oui, mais c'est pas c'est pas la
c'est c'est une question intéressante
ça.
C'est pour vous déconcentrer.
Oui. Oui.
Euh
oui. Bah écoutez,
parlez de quoi
hein ?
Parlez de quoi ?
Ben je sais pas si vous allez mordir.
Tong short crème solaire.
Ouais. Non, mais le la position des
politiques sur ces sujets-là, euh moi je
sais pas à quel moment euh François
Fillon dit ça. Il est dans un timing
politique, il a envie de faire une
annonce.
Il a peut-être raison.
Non, enfin j'en sais rien s'il a raison
mais c'est son problème. Mais nous en
tout cas dans notre dans notre travail,
on s'affranchit de ces polémiques
sur l'argent euh parce que son succès
enfin François Holland mon ennemi c'est
la finance, c'était du même ordre.
Enfin, je veux dire, il aurait mieux
fait de dire "Mon ennemi c'est le
carbone, hein. On en serait voilà là
finance le carbone."
Non, je veux dire que mon ennemi c'est
la finance, ça veut rien dire pour moi.
Et de même que on est dans on est on est
un pays surendetté, ça veut rien dire
non plus.
Ça veut rien dire
pour moi parce qu' quand on est sur les
quantités physiques et sur les usages,
c'est pas notre c'est pas notre
problème. Notre problème à nous. Et
quand je parle de marge de manœuvre,
c'est que on est encore un pays où les
gens
enfin une partie de la population vit,
une partie vit très bien et encore la
capacité à faire du tourisme, à partir à
étranger, à manger plus qu'elle ne
devrait.
Des étudiants qui s'odèrent pas.
Non mais il y a des inégalités et il y a
des problèmes mais il y a aussi creus
énormément. Oui, c'est vrai, c'est vrai
et ça un vrai problème mais globalement
au niveau de la richesse nationale, si
on compare la richesse nationale de la
France par rapport à d'autres pays, on a
encore des marges de manœuvre.
Mais ça ça tient pas la route ça.
On a encore des margû attention regarde
regarde le tir monde là si
non ce que je veux dire c'est que on a
du coup on a une responsabilité pour
avancer. Moi, j'entends quelquefois des
gens qui disent "Ouais, mais euh
pourquoi est-ce que nous on ferait
l'effort alors que les Chinois euh alors
que les les Russes enfin le dernier qui
a dit ça ? Euh, bon
les Américains
ou les Américains
le train de vie des Américains n pas
négociable". Oui. Mais attends, mais
c'est pas le problème. Qu'est-ce que tu
fais toi ? Qu'est-ce que voilà et dans
ton pays à toi, tu as encore des marges
main, pardon. Voilà. Et donc
c'est vrai ça encore avec un un système
interconnecté, mondialisé, intriqué avec
des flux énergétiques, avec des gens qui
ont des des mains sur des robinets pour
nous couper le gaz,
avec d'autres qui ont des mains sur les
boutons pour envoyer
Oui, il y a des gnomes partout qui nous
veulent du mal. Mais mais mais nous
il y a des gnomes partout qui nous
veulent du mal.
Vous pensez des des gnomes ? Vous parlez
desquels ?
Non, mais des gnomes qui s'occupent du
gaz, d'autres qui s'occupent de la Mais
nous ce qui nous intéresse, c'est ce
qu'on peut faire ici et maintenant dans
notre pays avec les leviers qu'on a. Je
peux être un peu provoque ? Je peux être
provoque.
Est-ce qu'on va pas se retrouver, on va
se pas se retrouver comme des petits
gnomes franco-français à se faire un un
bouton hypothétique euh alors que nos
voisins euh bougent pas ? Est-ce que
est-ce que la cupidité d'autres États,
le comportement prédateur sur les
ressources qui nous restent d'autres
États va pas mettre un petit peu votre
plan à la poubelle ?
Mais au contraire, notre plan c'est une
manière de c'est une manière de nous
garantir
sur terre. Mais non, mais c'est une
manière de nous garantir un mot qui est
revenu un petit peu à la mode récemment
qui s'appelle la souveraineté parce
qu'on se rend libre de ces
contrainte-là. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
là pendu euh à savoir ce que monsieur
Poutine va faire avec son gazoduc ?
parce qu'on est drogué hein à cette à
cette énergie fossile, ni plus ni moins.
Donc se s'affranchir de ça, c'est
s'éviter
tout un tas d'ennuis, tout un tas de
guerres qu'on est obligé de mener plus
ou moins directement pour continuer à
avoir notre dose
ou de faux prétextes.
Voilà,
rapporter la démocratie pour les petites
filles,
par exemple,
protéger contre le terrorisme,
ça c'est une autre affaire. Mais disons
qu'en tout cas
les mines au Nigè
Oui, ça je connais
compris les mines au Niger.
Non non, j'ai dit c'est une autre
affaire.
Mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que avec cette décarbonation c'est
évident pour nous cette décarbonation
qui est à notre main encore une fois
dans dans nos dans nos pays, dans nos
modes d'action, dans nos usages, c'est
s'affranchir de ces
de ces dépendances. Et donc c'est c'est
une affaire de liberté pour nous les
Français. C'est pas
c'est la liberté pour nous français,
c'est pas un truc euh
c'est pas quelque chose de résumé
trivialement, on est le coq français qui
monte à 5h du matin pour réveiller le
monte en haut de son tas de merde et il
fait coc
et bim, il se prend un coup de fusil.
Non,
ou une p une paire de pont
mais non au contraire c'est pas ça.
Mais on fait ça pour nous, on fait pas
je fais ça. Je je suis
Non, mais je suis d'accord. Mais moi je
pense que la transition, on fait ça pour
nous, on fait pas ça pour les autres
pour se regarder dans la glace. Non,
c'est
on met les noms des gens qui vous ont
financé pour dire voilà papi papi il a
quand même payé, il a essayé de faire
quelque chose. Regarde regarde regarde,
je suis je suis dans le livre qui devait
sauver
bah il y a 4000 personnes qui ont donné
un peu d'argent pour qu'on fasse ce
boulot. Voilà. Bon
qui avait envie de se regarder dans la
glace.
Je sais pas parce qu'on leur avait pas
dit qu'on mettrait leur nom dans le
bouquin. On l'a mis mais on leur avait
pas dit. Ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils
pensaient que c'était utile.
Jean-Marc,
je ça ça renvoie à l'échange qu'on a eu
tout à l'heure qui est pourquoi économie
française ? Euh parce que on parle de
choses qui sont à notre main. Donc
euh c'est des choses qu'on peut faire
euh quoi que fassent les autres. Alors,
on peut même rajouter que dans un monde
aux ressources limitées, plus les autres
s'en foutent sur la consommation de
ressources épuisables et plus nous, et
s'ils sont plus gros que nous,
plus nous on a intérêt à s'en défaire
puisque de toute façon ça nous rend
dépendant d'un morceau du gâteau sur
lequel les autres ont plus de facilité
d'accès. Euh donc c'est c'est on a aucun
intérêt à rester à rester dépendant de
ça. Alors pour Poutine à très court
terme, Poutine a autant besoin de nous
que nous on a besoin de lui.
Bah si
ça c'est c'est plus très vrai quand même
quand on si si parce que si je peux
finir ma réponse euh quand quand il y a
quand il y a Non non non c'est quand il
y a le tuyau de gaz qui part de chez lui
et qui arrive chez nous, il peut pas
prendre le tuyau de gaz et l'envoyer
chez les Chinois. D'accord. Donc à très
court terme il a autant besoin de nous
pour ses recettes à l'exportation.
un/ers du PIB rus, c'est quand même les
hydrocarbur euh que nous on a besoin de
son gaz pour se chauffer. Donc chacun
tient l'autre par la barbichette et
c'est du reste comme ça qu' qu' on été
conçus les échanges de gaz par pipe.
Est-ce que ça veut dire que à terme
monsieur Poutine aura toujours autant
besoin de nous que nous on aura besoin
de lui ? Non. Euh déjà quand il y aura
moins de gaz à nous envoyer bah le lien
de dépendance mutuelle sera un peu un
peu plus faible. Est-ce que ça veut dire
que ce soit satisfaisant de se dire
comme il a besoin de nous pour arrondir
ses fins de mois nous on est Non, c'est
pas satisfaisant. Euh je dis juste que
euh la probabilité que il nous coupe
durablement le gaz demain matin et pour
toujours me paraît extrêmement faible
encore une fois parce queon représente
une partie de ces recettes à
l'exportation. Euh la Russie c'est 1/3
du pétrole et 1/3 du gaz européen hein.
Donc c'est pas c'est pas complètement
négligeable comme
comme dépendance mutuelle, on va dire.
Et on est beaucoup plus mal sur le
pétrole que sur le gaz parce que le gaz
il il faut un tuyau et chacun est d'un
côté du tuyau. Le pétrole il faut un
terminal de chargement et le pétrolier
va où il veut. Donc euh si Poutine a
mieux a mieux ailleurs pour son pétrole,
euh on est plus mal vis-à-vis du pétrole
russe que vis-à-vis du gaz russe. Et
incidemment, un truc que j'ai découvert
au moment de l'entrée en vigueur de la
dernière Commission euh européenne, la
feuille de route de la commissaire
européenne à l'énergie ne comporte ne
comporte pas le mot pétrole.
C'est-à-dire dans la lettre de mission
qui lui a été adressée par madame
Vleyen, il n'y a pas le mot pétrole qui
est la première énergie consommée en
Europe.
Il y a le mot gaz. Il y a le mot
charbon, il y a le mot nucléaire, il y a
le mot renouvelable, il n'y a pas le mot
pétrole. Voilà. Donc euh le pétrole est
est beaucoup plus un angle mort euh des
des politiques européennes euh que le
gaz euh qui est déjà pas brillant en
terme de politique, mais pétrole c'est
pire. Donc pour en revenir à la à la
question de "Est-ce qu'on est nous des
bisous nours et est-ce queon est le coq
français chantant sur son tas de fumier
?" Euh c'est pas not
à 5h du matin
à 5h du matin de préférence
pour réveiller le monde pour prendre une
autre direction. C'est c'est pas notre
problème. Notre problème encore une
fois, c'est de faire un plan qui flotte
pour nous.
Pour nous.
Et si il flotte pour nous, c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure, je pense que
ça sera depuis que je travaille moi de
ce sujet de la décarbonation, à chaque
fois que la France a pris une
initiative, il y a des pays ailleurs qui
l'ont copié.
Oui, à chaque fois on a mis une
obligation molasonne et bien trop timide
sur la publication des émission de gaz à
effet de ser des entreprises. La France
a été un des premiers pays à faire ça.
Sinon, le premier, je crois, ça a été
copié ailleurs. On a mis une obligation
sur la publication de chiffres sur
l'empreinte carbone des des des acteurs
du monde financier. C'est pareil, c'est
molon, c'est pas du tout au niveau
auquel ça devrait être. le régulateur,
il comprend rien. Enfin bon, bref, c'est
c'est voir il y a très peu de gens qui
sont formés euh au sein des instances de
régulation pour vraiment décortiquer ce
que les entreprise publie donc et ce que
les acteurs financiers publient. Donc il
y a énormément de peintures vertes dans
cette histoire. Il n'empêche que euh
c'était une première et que ça a été
copié. On vient de voter en France une
loi sur l'empreinte carbone du
numérique. C'est pareil, c'est une
première, ça commence à être regardé
ailleurs. Donc pour le moment, on va pas
assez vite. Par contre, ce qui est très
intéressant à noter, c'est qu'à chaque
fois que on fait quelque chose chez nous
dans ce domaine-là,
loin euh de de de les autres pays, loin
de se dire "Ils sont en train de
déconner, les sont les déconner dans
leur coin, il y a plein de gens qui qui
se mettent à faire la même chose parce
que l'homme est un animal mimétique."
Donc c'est exactement pareil en ce qui
concerne le plan qu'on propose. Moi, je
suis fermement convaincu que si on
commence à faire les choses dans les
grandes largeurs et de façon pertinente,
on aura des suiveurs. C'est absolument
évident. Je prends les paris sans sans
hésiter. Bah, je vais je vais je vais
Ouais, non, on va on va pas se prendre
tout ça tout de suite. Non, parce que
l'animal mimétique là aujourd'hui, la
Chine ferme ses aéroports à
l'international pour se protéger de
micron et nous c'est la fête du slip
avec les mesures sanitaires, on va
arrêter. C'est peut-être parce qu'on a
les élections.
Le le virus ne passe pas le le bureau de
vote.
Alors, j'ai j'ai je ne suis pas
compétent pour parler du virus qui parle
pas du bureau de vote.
Vous avez eu le le le comment ça
s'appelle ? Ou
covid ? Moi je l'ai eu. Oui.
Vous avez été vacciné euh en plus
et vous avez été contaminé après la
vaccination ?
J'ai été contaminé après la vaccination.
Et quand
ça donne quoi quand on est vacciné ?
Qu'on se prend un covid ? C'est plus
léger ou
? Bah j'ai eu un peu mal au crâne de
jours de micro courbature dans la nuque
et j'ai toussé de jours. Voilà.
Cacamou quand même. Non
pardon.
Un petit cacamou.
Non non il m'est arrivé d'avoir la
chiasse et c'était pire donc non
vraiment
Laurent
non je pas
personne à risque vieux un petit peu
un peu vieux mais mais non je l'ai pas
eu. Non.
Vacciné.
Oui
d'accord.
Discipliné donc vacciné.
D'accord.
Voilà.
La discipline ça va être important.
Est-ce que la démocr on parlait de
est-ce que des mesures électorales enfin
ou démagogiqu donc j'ai rien à dire sur
le Covid par contre j'ai à dire un truc
sur ce qui vient de se passer chez EDF
ça c'estque
là où là où là le lien avec les
élections à venir est quand même
beaucoup plus facile est quand même très
facile à établir et là c'est on est plus
dans mon champ de compétence
donc DF de vendre à perte ou moins cher
à ses concurrent cit bien c'est pas bien
c'est
c'est une manœuvre préélectorale de
façon évidente dans les en en en grande
Bretagne et en Espagne, on a laissé les
ménages avec leur douleur, hein.
Genre, on a relevé en Grande-Bretagne le
plafond d'augmentation tarifaire de
combien ? 54 %.
Oui, enfin les factures ont pris plus 50
%. Alors, après l'autre chose qui est
dans notre domaine de compétence, c'est
que la raison pour laquelle on a des
chocs de prix de cette nature sur le gaz
et sur l'électricité,
sur le gaz, c'est à cause de la
dépendance que nous avons justement. Il
faut savoir que le gaz historique en
Europe, c'est le gaz de la mer du Nord.
La mer du Nord a passé son pic en 2005
euh et depuis euh l'approvisionnement
décline et la Norvège a passé son pic en
2018. C'était le dernier gros producteur
de la zone. Les les Pays-Bas se sont
effondrés euh pareil dans dans dans ces
eau-là 20189 euh et ils ont leur
production a été divisée par 10 en
quelques années. Enfin voilà.
Et euh donc le gaz est de plus en plus
importé euh mais on narrive pas à
compenser physiquement par des
importation le déclin de la mer du Nord
et donc la consommation de gaz en Europe
s'est inversée en 2005. Ça l'augmenté
puis prof elle s'est mise à à baisser et
comme elle a baissé de façon subie donc
ça ça renvoie au début de l'échange euh
bah de temps en temps il y a des choses
très bizarres sur les prix. Et quand on
regarde aujourd'hui les prix à terme du
gaz, j'ai regardé donc le notre cher
ministre de l'économie là euh s'appelle
déjà
Bruno Lemire a dit euh
je j'ai publié ce que déjà ce que ce que
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
donc je peux le répéter de prix du gaz.
Donc sur le prix du gaz, Bruno Lemer a
dit, "J'espère qu'en fin 2022, on sera
sorti d'affaires." Alors, quand vous
regardez les prix à terme pour la
prochaine saison de chauffe et pour la
saison de chauffe d'après, donc pour la
pour l'hiver 2022 2023 et pour l'hiver
2023-2024, hein, les prix à terme du gaz
sont les mêmes que ce qui sont
aujourd'hui sur le marché spot. Les
mêmes 80 € du MW euh sur pour le PEG en
France. J'ai regardé sur le marché
allemand sur et cetera, c'est partout
pareil. Bon donc et comme maintenant
qu'on a mis l'électricité dans le
marché, le prix du MWAW marginal qui est
celui qui fixe le prix de marché hein,
c'est très simple, une centrale à gaz,
c'est un rendement d'à peu près 50 %
donc on prend le prix du gaz, on
multiplie par 2, donc x 2 160,
je rajoute 100 € la tonne de CO2,
c'est-à-dire 50 € sur le voilà et je
suis à 1 MW à 250 € en gros, ce qui est
très exactement ce qu'on a en ce moment
sur le sur le marché spot. Donc le bazar
qu'on a en ce moment sur le gaz et
l'électricité.
Bon, je vais pas prendre des paris en
mettant ma tête sur le bio, mais il y a
de bonnes chance, il y a de bonnes
chances pour que il soit il soit encore
là un certain temps. Bon donc la réponse
à ce problème qui est un problème
structurel, c'est tout sauf faire les
poches des DF pour faire un chèque aux
français avant qu'ils aillent dans le
bureau de vote.
Ouais. Non mais c'est pas un chèque au
français là.
Si si si. Enfin, on a fait c'est on a
fait un chèque au concurrent déguisé. On
a fait un chèque aux concurrents en
espérant qu'ils allaient le répercuter
aux Français. Donc en plus dans les
trucs très farces de cette mesure, il y
a le fait qu'EDF doit financer une
filiale de Total. C'est quand même
rigolo, non ?
C'est l'amour.
Voilà. Donc un des trucs qui est
absolument évident, mais là pour le coup
euh il y a beaucoup de voix qui
commencent à se faire entendre, euh
c'est que euh un c'est évident que cette
mesure on peut on peut pas imaginer une
seconde qui est pas d'arrière-pensée
électorale, c'est évident à 3 mois des
élections. et de le ça rend urgent la
planification.
La on en revient à ce qu'on disait, on
peut pas laisser des structures qui ont
un pas de temps séculaire dans un marché
ouvert où les trucs changent tous les qu
matins. Ça n'a strictement aucun sens.
Il faut planifier. Et planifier, ça veut
bien dire que à un moment ou à un autre,
on restreint la liberté des acteurs de
marché. Donc ça veut pas dire supprimer
le marché. Ça veut dire qu'à un moment
on cadre les acteurs de marché en leur
disant "Vous avez le droit de jouer la
cour de récrée elle s'arrête là." Et en
ce qui concerne l'électricité, on a fait
une cour de récrée qui allait beaucoup
trop loin et tant qu'on a'ura pas changé
la façon dont la cour de récrée est
organisée, on aura ce qui vient de se
passer à interval. Enfin, ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment, on
l'aura de façon un peu structurelle.
Est-ce que notre financier veut ajouter
quelques petits mots ? Oui. Alors sur
non mais
c'est pas mon c'est pas mon financier,
j'ai pas de compte en banque
Non mais sur la planification le marché
en tout cas sur le sur le prix
d'énergie, on subit de toute façon
effectivement les sauts de cabris du
prix du pétrole d'abord en qui entraîne
qui entraîne tout le tout le reste hein.
Et pour ce qui est de du prix auquel
vend
EDF, l'électricité,
moi j'ai envie de dire c'est de toute
façon EDF ça appartient à l'État
français. L'État français c'est nous.
Euh c'est nos impôts. Donc tout ça c'est
poche droite, poche gauche. Donc un jour
je te donne sous forme de prix
d'électricité ce que je vais te
reprendre en impôt de l'autre côté. Euh
bon, c'est du bon tau mais c'est je veux
dire ça ça n'adresse euh c'est embêtant
pour les gens qui ont à payer ces
factures et donc il y a des gens qui
souffrent
en précarité énergétique dans des
passoirs passoir
moi politiquement je je je comprends
enfin évidemment on est en période
électorale mais je comprends
politiquement qu'on
soit sensible à ceux qui souffrent voilà
mais c'est une mesure fiscale.
C'est pas une mesure, c'est
on a aucun doute là-dessus.
Oui. Oui. Non non, mais c'est une mesure
fiscale, c'est une mesure d'aide, c'est
pas une mesure du prix de l'énergie
puisque de toute façon l'énergie c'est
EDF. EDF c'est l'État à 80 de toute
façon c'est l'État donc c'est nous. Donc
voilà donc on est dans une mesure d'aide
d'accompagnement des gens qui souffrent
par rapport à une facture d'énergie qui
augmente.
Oui ça c'est ça c'est le le ça c'est le
phrasé du directeur de communication.
Oui, on est plutôt
Ah ben non, j'ai pas j'ai pas d'intérêt
dans cette affaire. C'est pas des années
en finance.
Je vais reformuler ça différemment. On
est en période de pandémie.
Ouais.
Ce serait quand même dommage que les
gens aillent manifester sans masque à se
regrouper machin. J'avais pas vu ça sous
c
Non mais il faut un peu penser
gestionnaire quand même.
Oui oui c'est vrai. Bah voyez on n pas
encore à ce niveau-là. Et puis et puis
et puis euh à chaque fois quand il y a
plus de foin dans les rateliers, les
chevaux se battent, ça fait monter le
populisme et quand même là, ils sont
petit peu au cout,
ils ont des intérêts derrière quand même
chacun des dettes.
Ouais,
Jean-Marc,
moi je je suis pas contre le fait qu'on
aide les gens qui souffrent et de toute
façon, je l'ai dit par ailleurs, à court
terme, non mais à court terme, il y
avait pas d'autres choix à court terme,
il y a pas d'autres choix que d'alléger
la peine.
Bien sûr.
Par contre, l'instrument qui a été
choisi pour alléger la peine, c'est de
la politique de gribouille. Voilà, c'est
ça que je suis en train de dire.
J'ai pas bien entendu. Comment
c'est de la politique de gribouille.
Revenons à nos moutons. Euh le système
démocratique, le la théocratie, la
dictature, la pour certains la
cleptocratie
et quel est le meilleur système pour
gérer ? Est-ce qu'un système à la
chinoise
ou à la nord-coréenne
de planification communiste
comme il faut en disant écoute-moi bien
ta carte de rationnement d'égaw, c'est
comme ça ? tu t puis j'ai 25 caméras de
vidéos surveillance qui vont bien me
voir qui vont me dire il y a Big Brother
Big Brother chinois est-ce que est-ce
que en fait la démocratie c'est pas un
épiphénomène qui va se faire remettre à
sa place par des contraintes physiques
je suis pas pressé mais c'est un risque.
Alors le rationnement il a toujours
existé. Par exemple dans la construction
je sais pas si c'est encore en vigur
aujourd'hui, mais pendant longtemps, il
y a un truc qui s'appelait le
coefficient d'occupation des sols. Le
coefficient d'occupation des sols, c'est
un rationnement. C'est-à-dire, on dit
bah voilà, vous achetez un terrain et ça
vous donne le droit de construire tant
de mètres carrés puis pas plus. Et c'est
pas une affaire de prix, vous avez pas
plus de temps de mètres carré. Euh le il
y a il y a il y a des domaines dans
lesquels on est rationné par exemple sur
la largeur des voitures. On peut pas
payer aussi cher qu'on veut et avoir une
voiture aussi large qu'on veut. La
voiture elle a une largeur standard et
donc il y a une forme de rationnement
sur la largeur des voitures. Le système
des quotas d'émission qu'on a
aujourd'hui en Europe, c'est un système
de ticket de rationnement. Euh les
grossites émetteurs, on leur dit "Tu as
le droit d'émettre tant." Alors, il y a
une soupape qui est si tu aimais plus,
tu as le droit d'acheter à un de tes
petits copains qui lui a a émis moins
que l'autorisation qu'on lui a donné. ce
qu'il n'a pas utilisé. Donc c'est c'est
ça le c'est ça l'ajustement par le
marché qui fait le prix de marché. Mais
au début, c'est un système de ticket de
rationnement juste c'est des systèmes,
c'est des tickets de rationnement euh
négociables. Donc le fait que on limite
par les quantités, donc le fameux
rationnement est parfaitement compatible
avec la démocratie et on en a de très
très nombreux exemples euh sous les sous
les yeux de limitation par les par les
quantités. Euh pour prendre un autre
exemple euh sur lequel Laurent élaborera
un peu peut-être un peu, la norme
constructive qui vient d'être mise,
enfin qui vient d'être décidé la RE220
est une norme sur les quantités de CO2
auxquelles on a droit par mètre carré
construit et c'est pas une affaire de
prix. On n'a pas le droit de payer plus
pour avoir plus de CO2 par mètre carré
construit. Une obligation et puis si on
respecte pas l'obligation, on n pas le
permis de construire et on est pourtant
en démocratie. Donc le l'idée queon ait
des obligations des limitations par les
quantités en démocratie, c'est pas du
tout quelque chose d'incompatible. Je
donner un dernier exemple. Il est
normalement interdit de fumer maintenant
dans les restaurants et c'est pas une
affaire de prix. Donc là aussi, on a une
limitation par les quantités. La
quantité est zéro quand on est à
l'intérieur d'un restaurant, on a juste
pas le droit d'utiliser une cigarette et
on est voilà. Donc je pourrais continuer
comme ça. Il y a il y a il y a plein
d'exemples. Donc est-ce que le plan,
c'est-à-dire quelque chose d'un peu
dirigé est incompatible avec la
démocratie ? Je ne le crois pas. Je ne
le crois tellement peu que quand on
demande aujourd'hui à un certain nombre
d'acteurs du système, alors parle pas
des politiques, je reparle des
syndicats, des des du patronat et
cetera, est-ce que vous êtes confortable
avec l'idée qu'il faut un plan ? On a
fait l'expérience pas plus tard que
lundi 7 février au soir. Et la réponse
unanime que nous avons eu, c'est oui. On
avait déjà poser la question en
septembre 2021 lors de l'université
d'été des Shifters à un certain nombre
de responsables syndicaux, pas les
mêmes. Et la réponse à nouveau était ou
enfin à nouveau a plutôt été déjà oui.
Donc l'idée queon puisse
avoir quelque chose qui cadre l'action
et qui du coup restreint notre liberté,
c'est c'est enfin je veux dire il y a
plein de gens qui sont d'accord avec ça
et je vais finir avec un dernier
parallèle. Quand on construit un
logement et qu'on demande des plans à un
architecte, les plans c'est justement
fait pour être respecté et qu'on fasse
pas autre chose. Donc ça restreint la
liberté de la personne qui va monter les
planchers euh ou mettre les placards. Il
respecte le plan. Donc euh on on n'est
pas du tout euh on voit pas en quoi euh
le fait d'avoir un plan oblige à
renoncer euh à la démocratie et à une
forme de liberté qu'on a par ailleurs.
Par contre, ce qu'on croit c'est qu'on
est dans un pays qui a un un socle
culturel euh qui nous rend plutôt
amateur de ce genre de choses. La
liberté,
non, le planification,
la planification. Euh, on est un pays
qui aime bien ça plutôt euh globalement
et ça ça c'est plutôt une chance pour
nous. Euh donc je rend ça renvoie à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure. C'est pas
parce que les autres ont pas encore fait
que nous il faut pas considence.
Ça c'était à votre époque ça ? Non les
gars de la planification nucléaire et
tout ça. Non
non non non ça ça enfin au plus
exactement oui mais depuis qu'on a
arrêté de planifier et qu'on a dit la
main invisible du marché va s'occuper de
tout sûr qu'on soit beaucoup plus
avancé.
Donc transition sur le rang.
Ouais. Non, mais sur la planification,
la démocratie, je pense que justement
euh c'est précisément la planification
qui va nous éviter de tomber parce qu'on
aura rien fait dans le seul régime qui
nous permettra de prendre les mesures
d'urgence qui qui sera le régime
autocratique. précisément, c'est parce
qu'on est on a encore des marges de
manœuvre qu'on a encore un processus
démocratique parce que la planification
telle qu'on la conçoit, c'est un
processus aussi qui fait la place à la à
la discussion, à la concertation avec
les gens qui savent, avec les gens des
métiers et après on bâtit un plan sur
lequel on est d'accord. Ça nous permet
de planifier les efforts qu'on a à faire
et encore une fois de pas se retrouver
avec une espèce de loi martiale du
climat parce que quand on aura plus que
ça alors là oui, on sera dans des
mesures ultra autoritaires.
C'est pas déjà le cas
pas en France mais de temps en temps.
Par exemple en Chine en Chine par
exemple. Oui. Alors c'est pratique en
Chine là il trouvait que le mining ça
consommait trop d'énergie. Donc du jour
au lendemain ils ont interdit le mining
sur le territoire.
Donc le mining de monnaie digitale
ça consommait trop d'énergie. Et donc un
matin, il y en a un qui s'est levé qui a
dit "Bon, attends là, il y en a trop, je
ferme le robinet." Ça, chez nous c'est
pas possible. C'est possible chez eux,
c'est pas possible chez nous. Parce que
chez nous, c'est la démocratie, ça
fonctionne autrement. Voilà. Donc il y a
une liberté d'entreprendre, il y a une
imagination. Voilà, tout ça, ça va
ensemble. Imagination Chine,
enfin en tout cas pas notre manière à
nous, on va dire, hein. Donc,
il faut être créatif quand même pour
faire un contrôle social, un système de
contr crédit social.
En tout cas, en tout cas, la
planification n'est pas l'ennemi du tout
de la démocratie. Elle est précisément
la manière d'amener ces transitions dans
la paix et la planification dans nos
pays démocratique.
Et la bonne humeur.
La bonne humeur, je sais pas. Mais euh
en parlant de bonne humeur, euh
gouverner, c'est prévoir.
Comment
Oui. Oui. Il gouverne patron en ce
moment, j'ai l'impression.
Pourquoi vous rigolez, Jean-Marc ?
Au sens de gouverner ses prévoirs. Non,
évidemment. Euh mais mais on on le on le
sent bien encore une fois. Moi, j'ai
strictement rien ni pour ni contre notre
actuel gouvernement et notre actuel
président de la République. Non, mais je
veux dire ce que c'est pas une attaque
personnelle, je m'en fous. Et puis de
toute façon, j'ai enfin je veux dire
j'ai pas d'ambition dans ce domaineel.
Donc euh mais on sent bien que on a
depuis maintenant plusieurs mandatures,
des présidents et des gouvernements qui
ont comme but de s'emparer du pouvoir et
qui ensuite savent pas quoi en faire.
Euh donc, ils se mettent à avoir
justement le réflexe de Fillon qui est
ah je vais m'occuper d'argent parce que
ça je crois que je comprends. En plus,
ils croient qu'il comprennent.
pas toujours euh mais parce que c'est
par défaut, c'est parce que ils ont pas
de projet sur le reste. Euh alors qu'on
aille surtout pas me prêter une adhésion
à la à la vision du monde du bonhomme,
euh mais euh dans un livre que j'avais
écrit avec Alain Grandan,
d'ailleurs,
euh alors Alain Grandjean, vous avez
reçu ici, mais pas le livre. Le livre
c'était bon il y a longtemps euh j'étais
presque jeune. Euh on avait euh on avait
expliqué comment est-ce que euh le le
Hitler avait redressé l'économie
allemande et en fait il a fait ça en
disant l'argent je m'en fous. Alors, on
n' pas envie de suivre exactement son
programme, hein. Donc, mais je veux dire
par là, le fait de dire l'argent, il y a
que ça en fait, c'est c'est c'est masqué
un vide sur le projet lui-même. Bon, et
donc nos gouvernements successifs qui ne
s'occupent que d'argent, en fait, ils le
font parce qu'ils ont pas de projet à
côté de ça. Il voi il voi pas clair, ils
ont pas le sens de l'histoire, ils sont
ils sont dans le brouillard, ils voient
pas clair, il en fait il faut
conseiller, ils ont pas la ressource,
ils ont pas la ressource, ils ont pas la
compréhension et en fait il faut revenir
à la lecture physique du monde pour
retrouver un projet. C'est tant qu'on
est juste dans la convention,
on on on voit rien, on comprend rien. En
plus, on est entouré de courtisans.
Enfin, on voit rien quoi. Euh mais oui,
les les c'est l'Élysée, c'est c'est
c'est juste ils avaient pas de fou du
roi là-bas. Donc,
c'est la loi du genre. Partout, tout le
temps. Bon,
le bouffon du roi, j'ai compris.
Le fou du roi.
Ah, le fou du roi.
Fou du ro pas le bouffon. Le fou du roi.
Personne qui vous bent les fesses tous
les matins en disant donc
des bouffons là.
Non, il y a pas des bouffons. Il y a des
gens Il y a pas des bouffons. Il y a il
y a il y a il y a il y a un système qui
est un système d'isoloir euh et un
système malheureusement quand même
largement de courtisan quoi. Euh bon
donc le
mais c'est le système qui veut ça. C'est
pas c'est pas une affaire de personne.
C'est malheureusement c'est c'est plus
profond que ça. Et l'une des raisonsf
l'une des raisons pour laquelle le
système fonctionne comme ça encore une
fois c'est qu'il est pas porté par un
projet. Le projet c'est de s'emparer du
pouvoir. Une fois qu'on y est, on sait
pas quoi faire. Mais mais on n'est pas
en marche.
Si on fait des on fait des start-ups.
On fait des start Non non non, on fait
des écuries de licorne.
Écuries de licorne. Voilà.
D'accord.
Qu'est-ce qu'il en pense le financier
des écuries de licorne ? Est-ce que la
science et la technologie vont nous
sauver ou est-ce que la science et la
technologie ne vont pas nous sauver ?
La science si. La connaissance. Oui. La
connaissance. Ouais. La compréhension
des enjeux, ça peut nous sauver. Euh
donc ça c'est de la science. Oui, la
technologie c'est autre chose. Euh la
technologie, vous savez sur les
échéances qui sont les nôtres, la
technologie, elle fera pas grand-chose.
On parlait de la du véhicule automobile.
Enfin, les nouvelles technologies feront
pas grand-chose. Euh, il faut faire avec
les technologies qu'on a aujourd'hui
dont on sait qu'elles fonctionnent. Euh
la technologie de la batterie lithium
ion dans les dans les voitures, en fait,
elle a été expérimentée dans les WMAN il
y a 30 ans. Donc il il y a D'accord.
Donc ce que je veux dire c'est que il
faut faire avec ce qu'on a aujourd'hui.
Faut pas attendre de miracleur baladeur.
Ouais pardon Wman Sony. Bon donc en fait
il a fallu 30 ans pour que quelqu'un se
rende compte que
ce truc qui marchait pour un
pour écouter de la musique puisse servir
à transporter une voiture. C'est la même
technologie, ça a rien changé. Donc
voyez que la technologie non la
technologie fera pas de miracle. On ne
fera qu'avec les technologies
existantes. C'est un des parties pris
très forts du plan de transformation de
l'économie française. C'est qu'on ne on
ne on ne parie sur aucun gain
technologique dans les 30 années qui
viennent. On fait tout avec ce qu'on
sait faire aujourd'hui parce que
comme à l'armée. Non, c'est ça. On fait
on fait beaucoup de choses avec pas.
J'ai pas l'armée. J'ai du bord. Oui.
Ouais.
On fait que ce qu'on a pour être sûr
parce que il y aura quelques bonnes
surprises technologiques mais il y aura
c'est quand même honteux clairement.
Mais il y aura aussi des il y aura aussi
des trucs qu'on a pas prévu. Donc
c'est pas honteux que la France en
arrive euh là. C'est on a rien anticipé,
on se fait surprendre donc on a perdu et
on se retrouve avec un ingénieur, un
financier qui essaie de se retrousser
les manches avec
1000 de leurs copains pour dire là parce
que quand même bon on a ça fait quand
même on a on paye tous des impôts ici.
Euh on les paye pourquoi ? Juste pour
maintenir le vernis social pour faire
quoi ? C'est c'est pas dramatique que
nous
Non Jean-Marc
non euh
je ne crois pas. Je crois qu'en fait la
la façon dont alors je je suis pas un
grand historien mais j'ai j'ai
l'impression, je vais me limiter à ça
après demain,
j'ai l'impression que en régime
tranquille
la démocratie ne sait pas créer une
vision au sein de son personnel
politique.
Et en fait quand on quand on regarde
les gens qui ont eu des destins un peu
hors norme
dans notre pays,
il a fallu souvent des crises euh pour
qu'ils arrivent et il a fallu souvent
des crises, ça je pense que c'est assez
biologique euh pour que une nouvelle
vision émerge et soit portée. Euh donc
moi, il me semble que c'est juste le
fonctionnement normal, c'est une espèce
de darwinisme normal. Euh et c'est et ça
renvoie à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur le fonctionnement du système
politique dont on hérite aujourd'hui.
C'est un système qui s'est fait sur un
monde en croissance, donc un monde
tranquille euh sans problème euh où la
seule question c'est de distribuer du
rap de sucette. Mais bon ça tout le
monde sait faire.
Subvention, c'est ça
du rap de sucette. Non
gérer l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat,
vous moi, n'importe quel crétin venu,
c'est faire ça. Faut dire pas besoin
d'avoir des grandes compétences. Gérer
la rareté, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué. Voilà. Donc là, on a des gens
qui sont arrivés en pensant qu'ils
allaient gérer l'abondance et qui
doivent se retrouver à gérer la rareté.
Donc ils sont perdus, il ils savent ils
savent pas faire. Euh et les gens qui
donc ils ont pas les ils ont pas les ils
ont pas le le je sais pas le le bagage
intellectuel pour faire ce genre de
chos. C'est c'est pas leur monde quoi.
Euh et donc c'est normal que ce soit euh
des branquignoles comme nous qui s'y
collent. Mais c'est nous, ça aurait pu
être d'autres. Ce que je veux dire,
c'est que c'est normal que ça vienne de
l'extérieur pour
pour imaginer un peu plus la chose. Donc
on est sur un bateau,
il y a il y a plus à bouffer ou il y a
il y a moins à bouffer. Si
si, il y a encore à bouffer aujourd'hui.
Il y a encore un peu à bouffer avec
l'inflation. Mais oui
oui.
Et donc donc il
ce qu'il y a pas aujourd'hui avec
l'inflation, c'est que il y a pas assez
pour manger plus le téléphone plus la
voiture plus le logement plus les jouets
pour Noël plus la piscine plus
l'abonnement à la clarinette pour la
petite dernière plus c'est ça
le pilate au Racing. Euh or euh il faut
bien voir que tout ça c'est des trucs
qu'on a empilé les uns sur les autres à
mesure que euh grâce à l'abondance
énergétique notre pouvoir d'achat
augmentait. Et aujourd'hui euh ce qu'on
ne sait pas faire c'est une forme de
hiérarchie indolore des renoncements ou
des renoncements indolores. C'est c'est
ça qu'on sait pas gérer euh parce que
c'est nouveau parce que ça fait de
siècles qu'on est dans l'expansion et
donc on n pas de réflexe lié. Alors, il
y a quand même eu des phases un peu
pendant la guerre occupation, mais euh
on a on n pas eu de
voilà subi, mais on on n pas de réflexe,
on n' pas de réflexe structurel, j'ai
envie de dire, sur la façon de se
limiter, de voilà. Donc ce qui est ce
qui est douloureux aujourd'hui, c'est
que on voudrait, parce que c'est ça en
plus la promesse politique, tout
conserver
dans un monde dans lequel ça va être
compliqué.
Voilà. Et au lieu de se dire bah oui, ça
va être compliqué mais peut-être qu'il y
a des trucs, bon on les a aujourd'hui
mais enfin si on les a plus, c'est
vraiment pas un drame. Euh non, on se on
on on continue à se baser sur une
promesse qui ne peut être que déçue qui
est laissez-moi faire et votre pouvoir
d'achat va augmenter.
C'est c'est c'est pour ça que ça
disfonctionne. Et là, effectivement,
dans ce genre de contexte, les choses ne
peuvent que mal se passer. Donc c'est ce
propos me pousse à rebondir sur la
sobriété heureuse. Vous parlez beaucoup
de sobriété et de côté il faut donner un
objectif, quelque chose de sympa, que ce
soit
pas an oxyogène, il faut il faut donner
envie. Question internet, peut-on se
passer de pétrole sans changement
radical dans notre vie ? Mode de vie ?
Non.
Question question suivante.
Il faut il faut qu'on élabore.
Ouais. Ouais. Il faut délayer un peu.
Il faut délayer un peu. Alors euh le
pétrole aujourd'hui c'est les
transports. Euh
c'est les chaussures, c'est les
chaussettes. Non, c'est les chaussettes
en laine.
Tout ce qui n'a pas été euh Vous étiez
pas obligé de dire ça parce que c'est
vraiment pas des chaussettes trendy,
mais c'est pas grave. Euh
les chaussettes barbour.
Oui. En fait, c'est parce que c'est des
chaussettes qui permettent de pas avoir
trop froid au pied quand je serai
dehors.
Parce que vous venez en vélo et vous
avez 30 km à faire en vélo ce soir
parce que aujourd'hui je suis venu en
vélo et que effectivement il va falloir
que je rentre en vélo et que nous ne
sommes pas en plein été dans le désert
sans crème solaire comme tout à l'heure
là
et en tongue. Voilà donc euh et si j'ai
les pieds un peu moins gelés à
l'arrivée, je voilà. Donc mon premier
critère c'était pas ce que vous aviez
pensé de mes chaussettes, c'était est-ce
que j'aurais pas trop froid au pied en
pchement côté fonctionnel. Oui,
on peut dire ça. Euh et donc euh le tout
ce qui dans cette pièce a nécessité des
matières premières qui ne sont pas
situées à côté de cette pièce. Tout ce
qui dans cette pièce a nécessité une
étape de fabrication qui n'est pas à
côté de cette pièce, à nécessité des
transports, donc du pétrole. Donc en
fait, il y a pas un objet dans cette
pièce, je dis bien pas un, qui est
échappé dans sa chaîne de valeur à la
disponibilité en pétrole. Bon euh donc
si on demain matin, c'est totalement
comment dire c'est c'est c'est c'est
pour le fun ce que je vais dire parce
que ça ça n'a pas de sens. Mais si
demain matin on devait de plus avoir de
pétrole du tout. Demain matin là
pour le fun.
Oui pour le fun. Il y a plus un camion
qui circule
donc les gens dans les villes n'ont plus
à bouffer. Il y a plus un vêtement qui
est mis à disposition. Il y a plus une
entreprise manufacturière qui peut se
faire livrer. Il y en a plus une qui
peut expédier sa production euh et
cetera et cetera. Donc en gros euh on
voit bien que c'est un monde
instantanément à l'arrêt, ce qui est une
autre manière de dire que un monde sans
pétrole est un monde quand même assez
différent du monde dans lequel nous
sommes.
Ça s'appelle la perd d'assasse de
Poutine.
Ça s'appelle la quoi ?
La perd d'assas.
La perd d'assass.
La perd d'assass. Ah oui, pardon.
Absolument.
Euh la deuxième chose pour laquelle le
pétrole nous est indispensable, c'est
que le 15 % du pétrole qu'on utilise
dans le monde sert de matière première
pour la pétrochimie.
Alors la pétrochimie, c'est les banilons
que vous allez mettre dès que vous
sortirez de cette pièce parce que vous
avez une deuxième vie. Euh c'est tous
les ingrédients en plastique.
Mais j'aime les banilons.
Et ben, je le savais.
Mais vous savez, ma grand-mère m'a
expliqué que pendant la guerre,
vous aimez les mettre ou vous aimez les
voir chez les autres ? Ma grand-mère m'a
expliqué pendant la guerre que elle
faisait des traits derrière.
Oui.
Pour faire croire qu'elles avaient des
bas. Ah
der Est-ce qu'on va être obligé de se
refaire des fausses coutures pour
prétendre à
euh probablement que on va à un moment
ou à un autre euh essayer de garder des
références culturelles
avec moins de moyens. C'est absolument
évident.
Mais donc pour revenir à ce que je
disais 15 % donc la rallonge électrique
là c'est du plastique, c'est du pétrole.
Tous les composants dérivés du plastique
et cetera dans les caméras qui sont en
train de nous filmer, c'est du pétrole.
Euh il y a du pétrole, il y a des
dérivés du pétrole dans l'ordinateur,
dans la table, dans voilà dans toutes
les ma polaire là c'est du pétrole. Euh
dans les composants électroniques.
Voilà le micro c'est c'est du c'est du
c'est du pétrole. Enfin voilà du
pétrole, il y en a absolument partout.
Toutes les fibres synthétiques, c'est du
pétrole ou du gaz. Pétrole ou du gaz.
euh un tout petit peu de la biomasse
mais pas beaucoup. Donc le la le pétrole
aujourd'hui c'est la c'est la c'est les
transports et les transports c'est la
vascularisation de l'économie. Euh et
puis il y a aussi partout du charbon
dans cette pièce. Le charbon c'est la
fabrication de l'acier et de l'acier
absolument partout. Euh le charbon c'est
toute l'électricité qui a utilisé qui a
été utilisée pour faire tout ce qui est
made in charbon c'est-à-dire made in
China. et des trucs made in China
partout dans cette c'est aujourd'hui si
vous allez essayer d'acheter une petite
cuillère ou un couteau qui soit pas
fabriqué en Chine bon courage si les la
encore opinel mais enfin bon quand même
pas grand-chose. Euh donc on on voit
bien qu'on est environné de combustible
fossil et on vit dans un monde qui est
mondialisé de fête de singing ping.
Voilà. Donc le donc détricoter ça va
être long et compliqué, c'est absolument
évident. Mais à l'arrivée, ça donne un
monde alors qui pour partie ressemble à
celui d'aujourd'hui. Par exemple, on
mange toujours un monde avec ou sans
carbone, on mange. Bon,
pour ceux qui arrivent encore,
pas la même chose. Ah bah si on y arrive
pas du tout, on finit par mourir. Donc
on mange. Mais euh ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'on mangera pas nécessairement
la même chose, mais on continue à
manger. C'est un monde dans lequel on va
continuer à rire. Enfin, en tout cas,
faut l'espérer. Euh,
continuer d'avoir de la culture,
de la culture, de la communication, des
des sociétés organisées et cetera parce
que c'est génétique. On va continuer à
prendre soin de notre santé du mieux
qu'on pourra. Mais on va le
Ça veut dire quoi du mieux qu'on pourra
?
Bah, ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
l'hôpital c'est 8 % de l'empreinte
carbone de la France. Enfin, le système
de santé, pardon, pas l'hôpital, le
système de santé, mais l'hôpital se
taille la part du Lyon. C'est 8
priv.
Tout compris, mais c'est essentiellement
public. C'est 8 % de l'empreinte carbone
de la France. Donc c'est pas
complètement ridicule. Euh et la
question c'est si on veut lui aussi
l'entraîner dans la direction d'une
baisse de 5 % par an des émissions,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Donc on s'est pos
on s'est posé cette question. Ça veut
dire quoi se soigner dans un monde bas
carbone ? Bon euh avec des Bah oui, ça
veut dire quoi ? Bon euh les poches en
plastique, les seringues, les
cathéteres, les machins et cetera.
Enfin, vous avez un milliard de Laurent,
elle vient d'où ? Elle est en plastique.
Elle est pas en plastique.
Quelle poche ?
Ah mais on parlait médical.
Ah ouais. Non, j'ai pas de poche là.
On est trop jeune pour ça.
Mais euh donc
vous préparez les gars.
Bah ouais, on sait. Ouais, justement
c'est pour ça qu'on se préoccupe de la
santé.
La vessie de chèvre.
Ouais. Ou là.
Est-ce que vous êtes pas quand quand vos
détracteurs vous disent voilà je suis
désolé de vous couper.
Ouais. Vos vos détracteurs disent voilà
mais ça c'est les amis,
c'est les c'est les gens qui qui croient
plus dans le système créatif, c'est ceux
qui qui veulent nous faire vivre comme
au moyenage ruaga machin.
La rutabaga machin.
Ouais. Ouais. Non non mais ça on
entendait ça il y a 4 5 ans. Ça c'est
vrai. Plus maintenant. Plus jamais
maintenant. Plus jamais. Plus jamais on
nous dit euh mais votre truc c'est
rétrograde. Non non là le le le vent a
changé de de côté. C'est très clair.
D'abord parce que toute la jeune
génération
est totalement convaincue que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut s'y prendre. Donc en
fait
c'est quoi vos stades ? C'est quoi vos
sources ? Parce que la jeune génération,
on les voit se radicaliser
politiquement.
Euh la jeune génération c'est la
génération qui fait devant les
téléphones portables avec la bouche en
canard. La jeune génération si c'est
ceux qui fantasment sur les hobby des
footballeurs qui rêvent de devenir
footballeur ou influenceuse. Donc c'est
quoi ? C'est quoi ? C'est c'est
vous vous de la jeune génération.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai qu'on voit des
jeunes, moi je vais parler de de gens
qu'on fréquente, les jeunes
professionnel
de quel âge ?
De bah de 20 à 30 ans. Tous les gens qui
dans le monde qu'on que je fréquente
moi, enfin qui est un monde de
d'entreprise de de gens qui travaillent
par exemple. Voilà. Mais j'en connais
vraiment pas beaucoup qui sont pas
totalement convaincus qu'on a raison de
proposer ces mesures là.
Donc ils ont une très bonne connaissance
de ce qu'il faut faire. Ils sont ils
sont vachement aguéris sur ces ordres de
grandeur et cetera. les vieux non enfin
les gens de notre âge qui sont au
pouvoir eux moi j'ai 50 on a le même 59
mais les gens qui sont pouvoir qui ont
mon âge moi j'ai donc parce que
euh eux ils ont ils ont le pouvoir donc
c'est eux qui tiennent les manettes
c'est eux qui tiennent les manettes mais
mais eux ils n'ont pas la connaissance
ils ont pas appris plus jeunes ils ont
pas puis entre-temps ils ont fait
d'autres choses donc ils ont pas pris le
temps de réapprendre donc on a des
jeunes qui savent
et des vieux qui peuvent
mais en fait c'est l'inverse du dicton
euh si jeunesse savait si vieillesse
pouvait hein. C'est l'inverse
aujourd'hui. C'est notre affaire c'est
si
bah oui voilà c'est ça c'est vieillesse
savait si jeunesse pouvait parce que les
jeunes ils savent mais évidemment ils
ont pas le pouvoir encore. Donc ça va
arriver parce qu'ils vont finir par
prendre les postes et cetera. Problème
c'est qu'on a pas 20 ans pour
attendre qu'il prennent le pouvoir.
Est-ce que vous avez peur que les jeunes
se vengent ?
Oh bah là on sera mort nous. Donc c'est
pas grave.
Quand on dit quand les jeunes se
vengeront, est-ce que vous avez pas peur
un petit peu que la génération qui
arrive là se dise "Bon bah ils ont bien
profité les gars, c'était bien cool. Ils
ont fait la fête, Champagne, gogo,
banilon et et horbord, grosse voiture.
Ouais,
ils nous ont foutu un monde, on se tape
sur la gueule, on se prend des coups de
soleil toutes les 5 minutes où il y a
des avalanches de criquet, il y a il y a
des rats de marée, ça devient plus
vivable. Donc les actifs financiers, le
patrimoine des vieux, terminé.
Votre iPad, on va on va le changer en
comme les comme en Amazonie, on vous
laisse avec un petit peu à bouffer puis
on vous laisse tout seul.
Sympa.
Est-ce que vous avez peur de ça ?
Oui, enfin, j'ai pas peur pour moi parce
que
encore des actifs.
Non, puis bon, comme les jeunes on ils
nous connaissent maintenant, nous on est
des vieux mais que les jeunes
connaissent. Non, je plaisante. Non,
mais j'ai pas peur pour moi parce qu'on
raisonne pas avec la peur. Mais oui,
j'ai peur pour le Moi, je je pense
qu'effectivement il y a il y aura ce il
y aura cette amertume. Ouais. Les
jeunes. Ouais. Il y aura cette amertume
que la génération d'avant qui est celle
qui avait le pouvoir, les vieux qui
pouvaient n'ont pas n'ont pas su et donc
n'ont pas fait. Oui, ça c'est clair.
Changeons de sujet un peu plus léger.
Je peux faire un complément là-dessus Et
bien entendu,
je je vais faire le lien entre les deux
questions, c'est-à-dire Instagram machin
et euh la vengeance des jeunes. Je pense
qu'une partie de la vengeance des
jeunes, elle risque de se faire mais
sans qu'ils aient conscience que c'est
de ça dont ils se vengent. C'est-à-dire
que en fait
une partie des jeunes
je pense que beaucoup de la jeune
génération, même les Instagram, ils
sentent confusément qu'il y a un truc
qui va pas. Oui.
Euh sur la partie qui nous concerne, les
sujets environnementaux et cetera, ils
en entendre parler. Euh ils ont pas
nécessairement
réseaux sociau,
ils ont pas nécessairement compris de
quoi il retournait mais euh il il ils en
entendent parler et ils comprennent bien
qu'il y a un truc qui va pas.
Pour autant, ils sont pas nécessairement
capables de faire le lien avec
l'inaction des décideurs en place. Par
contre, quand les problèmes
involontaires arriveront, euh les
problèmes de stress économique, euh les
problèmes d'immigration massive et
cetera, à ce moment-là, ils feront ce
qu'on fait les jeunes parce qu'ils sont
jeunes, pas parce que ils sont
exactement, ils se mettront sur la
gueule parce que les les les les
belligérans sont souvent plus jeunes.
Bon euh et ça sera une façon, entre
guillemets de mettre la génération
d'avant dans une situation encore plus
difficile que celle qu'elle connaissait.
Mais je suis pas sûr que ça sera
conscientisé sur la question
environnementale. Par contre, je pense
qu'il y a un vrai risque euh oui
effectivement euh que la génération du
dessus pâtisse du fait que la génération
d'en dessous va remer fort parce qu'elle
sera placée dans une situation qui lui
plaira pas du tout.
Revenons à notre sobriété heureuse. Euh
on va prendre les vieux. Vous avez
renoncé à quoi vous ?
Fini la Ferrari, fini les voyages au
Mald. Moi, j'ai jamais eu de Ferrari.
J'ai dû acheter deux voitures dans ma
vie.
Vous un chauffeur ?
Ouais. Première chose que j'ai fait
quand j'étais patron de CLPre, c'est que
je me suis
Vous gagné combien à l'époque ?
1 million d'euros
par an.
Ouais. J'étais le moins bien payé des
patron 40 mais bon. Il
il en reste quoi maintenant ?
Bah
pas un petit peu mais pas grand-chose.
Vous avez procédé à de l'évasion fiscale
?
Non, trop compliqué.
C'est beaucoup trop compliqué.
Faut faut il faut s'en occuper ça. Je
veux dire c'est c'est un
million d'euros net bruts.
Ah non c'est c'est brut parce qu'après
il y a il y a tout un il y en a 60 % qui
part à l'état et c'est très bien comme
ça.
Vous êtes pour une augmentation de la f
Non là c'est bien 60 % c'est pas mal. Je
pense que c'est bien. Franchement moi
les footballeurs quand on dit qu'ils
sont payés 40 millions, je trouve ça
super parce que il y en a 24 qui part à
l'état donc moi je me réjouis. Non mais
voilà. Non mais les rémunérations, les
salaires sont très bien taxés. C'est
très bien comme ça. C'est bien. Voilà.
pas un peu plus.
Moi je trouve c'est bien 60 %
franchement. Après bon,
je vous dis au-dessus de 10000 balles
par mois, je vous prends tout.
Bah ça c'était genre marcha ou
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon audessus au-dessus
de 12 millions. Je prends tout en ISF.
Ouais. Voilà. Donc euh
non c'est
Vous avez renoncé à quoi alors ? Vous
voyage
ou
vous avez fait combien de tours du monde
? Combien de fois le tour du monde ?
Assez peu. Moi j'ai fait les États-Unis
et l'Europe. Jamais allé en Asie de ma
vie. L'Afrique un peu.
Non, moi je suis assez casagier donc
j'ai pas renoncé à tant de choses que
ça. Vous avez
un gros château ?
Non.
Combien de femmes ?
J'en ai qu'une et je la salue si elle me
regarde.
Donc que les voyages.
Ouais.
Mais tous les jours. Vous avez renoncé à
quoi ? Mais pas tant de choses que ça.
La viande.
Ah la viande ! Bah oui, on en fait en la
viande. Ouais, viande
barbac. Vi,
j'en ai jamais mangé beaucoup. Ouais.
Non mais voilà, il y a plein de
Non, j'ai pas renoncé à grand-chose en
fait. Voilà. Mais je pense pas que
j'avais une vie euh déjà euh très euh
Vous étiez déjà frugal.
Qu'est-ce qui doit rester comme pognon ?
Ouais, c'est ça. Ouais.
Jean-Marc.
Alors, je remarque quand même, on doit
dire que vélo, il monte les escaliers à
chaque fois, il descend les escaliers.
Ça c'est pas pour le climat,
c'est pour vous.
Oui,
mais c'est donc vous avez coûté moins
cher la société.
Euh alors, c'est une question que je me
suis posé, du reste, on a beaucoup
discuté dans le groupe santé du PTEF.
Est-ce que si les gens s'entretiennent
mieux, il me il coûte moins cher à la
société en mourant ou il meurent juste
d'autres choses ? Un peu plus tard et ça
coûte le même pognon. Voilà. et on a des
débats pas complètement conclusifs euh
sur le sur la question. Euh par contre,
ce qui est sûr, c'est que entre-temps
euh on se sent mieux euh et que si on se
sent mieux, on a meilleur moral. Si on a
meilleur moral, on fait plus de choses
euh et la vie est plus agréable. Donc je
le fais d'abord pour ça. Du reste euh
une des choses dont je suis profondément
convaincu et on en revient à la question
sansernelle de fois obliger les gens fa
et cetera, je suis intimement convaincu
que en fait il faut que les mesures
qu'on propose on arrive à les rendre
désirabl et qu'on arrive à les rendre
désirables pour quelque chose qui est un
bénéfice de court terme qui n'a rien à
voir avec le climat. Alors, je vais
donner un exemple sur l'emploi. Si les
gens sentent que ils ont de la
visibilité sur l'emploi qu'ils peuvent
occuper, qui leur plaît par ailleurs et
euh un avenir professionnel pour leur
gosse, euh c'est quelque chose qui est
désirable tout de suite. C'est moi, si
on me dit tout de suite tes enfants euh
ils vont se choisir une voix qui va leur
apporter
20 ans de sécurité, je signe demain
matin et j'ai pas besoin de enfin si on
me propose ça, je me fous du climat.
C'est ça qui va m'intéresser. Non, mais
je veux dire donc si dans le cadre d'un
plan qui est bon pour le climat, on est
capable de me proposer ça,
ça me ça me plaît. Euh sur le côté euh
vélo, en fait le vélo, je m'y suis mis
parce qu'il se trouve que j'habite en
banlieu. Il se trouve que je m'y suis
mis au moment de la grève de la RATP qui
a eu lieu il y a 2 ans et demi. Là, il y
avait plus de RER du tout sur ma ligne.
C'est
un vélo français ou un vélo de made in
Portugal ?
Euh, alors les vélos made in France
aujourd'hui, j'en ai il y en a pas
beaucoup. Euh donc c'est un vélo euh je
ne je ne pense pas que le mien a été
assemblé en France. Euh parce que en
fait il a 10 ans euh mon vélo et pour ne
rien vous cacher, c'est le vélo de ma
fille que j'emprunte
souvent
parce qu'il a fait un peu raler mais
bon. Euh donc c'est un vélo, je pense
pas qu'il était fabriqué en France mais
peu importe.
Est-ce que vous êtes radin ?
Non parce que à l'époque des vélos
fabriqués en France, il y en avait juste
pas. Pour prendre un autre exemple,
quand j'ai
Bah parce que en l'occurrence elle s'en
sert pas.
Donc je lui est renoncer à la propriété.
Une seule question à la fois. Donc euh à
quoi j'ai renoncé ? Euh donc le vélo, je
n'en fais je il y aurait pas de problème
de climat, je ferai le même parce que au
moment où je suis venu à Paris en vélo,
je me suis dit tiens c'est pas mal. Euh
moi qui suis assis le cul sur une chaise
toute la journée, je vais faire ça une
fois par semaine, ça me fera du bien. Et
donc aujourd'hui, on me dirait que il y
a le CO2 n'a aucune espèce d'incidence
dans l'air. Je continuerai quand même à
faire mon vélo une fois par semaine euh
pour des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le climat. Et je je dis ça mais
c'est le défi. Donc en fait je refuse de
m'ériger en bon exemple en disant
"Regardez ce que je fais, je le fais pas
du tout pour le climat, je le fais pour
moi." Sauf que il se trouve que c'est
bon pour le climat et en fait c'est le
défi sur tout ce qu'on doit proposer. Ça
doit toujours être d'abord bon pour la
personne qui le fait. Elle doit y
trouver quelque chose d'intéressant, pas
nécessairement tout mais quelque chose
d'intéressant. Et aussi il faut que ce
il faut marier les deux et que ce soit
bon pour le le climat. Alors à quoi
est-ce que j'ai renoncé ? Moi, j'ai
renoncé à l'avion. Euh mais c'est pas un
gros effort parce qu'au fond je suis
comme Laurent, je suis assez casagier.
Euh le le ou plus exactement le voyage
qui me dépays, c'est le voyage lent. Euh
j'ai pris le train pour aller en Suède
il y a une dizaine d'années parce que
j'avais été invité à faire une
conférence en Suède par l'ambassade de
France et je leur ai dit "Je veux bien
mais vous me payez le train pour venir,
je prends pas l'avion." Et en fait
j'étais ravi de leur avoir dit ça parce
que j'ai traversé l'Allemagne, le
Danemark, la Suède. C'était super sympa.
J'ai vu à quoi ça ressemblait. J'aurais
pris l'avion, je serais allé d'un
aérogar à un autre aérogar et j'aurais
vu Copenhag euh j'aurais vu Stockholm
puis c'est tout. J'aurais rien vu
d'autre. Là, j'ai vu les forêts
suédoises, à quoi ça ressemblait, la
gueule des baraques et cetera.
Intéressant.
Et euh le le le jour de ma vie,
vous savez pourquoi ? Parce que
l'important, c'est pas la destination,
c'est
c'est le voyage. Absolument. Et le jour
de ma vie où j'ai eu le plus
l'impression d'arriver au bout du monde,
euh c'est le le c'est un jour où on
avait traversé de Bretagne jusqu'en
Irlande en bateau et en arrivant sur la
côte, on avait passé la nuit blanche et
on on arrive au petit matin sur la côte
irlandaise dans la brume et cetera et
j'avais vraiment l'impression et ça
faisait une semaine qu'on était parti de
Saint-Valou, j'avais l'impression d'être
arrivé au bout du monde. J'ai jamais eu
cette impression dans l'avion, jamais.
Donc le donc arrêtez de prendre la
viande sur ça ne m'a coûté aucun effort.
Voilà donc je je c'est pas un brevet
d'or beaucoup aucun effort. Je mange
moins de viande. Alors ça des fois ça me
coûte un tout petit peu, je le
reconnais. Euh mais euh pas plus que ça.
Pas pas pas un truc euh voilà. Et j'ai
quasiment arrêté le bof. Je vais je me
prends deux pote au feu par hiver et
puis ça s'arrête à peu près là. Et ça me
coûte absolument pas. Euh je fais partie
de la catégorie d'hommes qu'il faut
traîner dans un magasin pour leur
acheter quelque chose. Donc c'est il y a
deux catégories d'hommes hein. Il y a
François Fillon et non pardon. Euh donc
il y a ceux qui sont des acheteurs
compulsifs. Euh et puis il y a ceux euh
il faut leur dire vraiment tu as tuas tu
as l'air d'un clodo va va t'acheter. Moi
je suis plutôt dans la 2è catégorie donc
ça me coûte strictement rien euh de pas
aller faire les soldes, de pas acheter
des machins, pas acheter de derniers
gadgets et cetera parce que j'ai horreur
de ça. Voilà. Donc je je en gros je n'ai
vraiment renoncé pas à grand-chose et
les trucs qui me tiennent vraiment à
cœur, j'y renonce pas mais j'ai la
chance que ce soit des trucs globalement
pas très émissifs concernant mais c'est
une chance, j'ai pas fait exprès comme
ça.
Laurent, est-ce qu'il faut renoncer à la
propriété ? Est-ce qu'il faut continuer
à faire autant de gamins ? Est-ce qu'il
faut pas baisser un peu les la natalité
? Est-ce qu'il faut euh Non,
bah moi j'ai renoncé à faire des gamins,
j'en ai fait trois puis après j'ai
arrêté. Donc euh voilà, déjà moi j'ai
pris mes dispositions. Euh
ça c'était à votre époque ?
Oui, c'est ça. C'était il y a longtemps.
Et donc est-ce qu'il faut annoncer à la
propriété ? J'entendais votre question.
Je suis pas sûr que ça fasse moins de
CO2. Bah le moins de CO2, imaginez-vous,
on détient pas sa voiture.
Bah oui, mais ce qui Non, mais ce qui
est important c'est l'usage. C'est pas
la propriété de la voiture qui fait
consommer le CO2, c'est l'usage de la
voiture. Donc euh
non, je pense pas que ça résolve aucun
problème. Par contre, je
perche quand même.
Ouais, c'est sympa. Non, mais c'est
l'usage. Mais j'ai loué des voitures
pendant des années, c'est pour ça que
toutes des millions de voitures. Voilà.
Et donc euh mais euh non, je pense enfin
ce qui est important c'est de changer
les usages. On avait évoqué en en début
d'entretien euh la mobilité la mobilité
urbaine versus la la mobilité longue. Ce
qui ce qui compte c'est d'identifier
quels sont les usages et les adresser de
la façon la moins carbonée possible sans
renoncer à l'essentiel
ni au plaisir de faire les choses. C'est
possible. Voilà. Et la propriété a pas
grand-chose à voir avec la avec ça et
c'est un tout autre sujet. Voilà. Donc
pour revenir à autre chose, la
fiscalisation des vieux.
Ouais.
Est-ce que la transmission du patrimoine
qui est en fait
du carbone stocké, non ?
Est-ce qu'il faut fiscaliser plus ou
moins le patrimoine
dans la dans la succession ?
Mais c'est c'est lié au
Vous y avez bossé un petit peu de ça
dans votre programme ?
Non. Non,
mais c'est lié à sujet c'est lié au
sujet précédent de la propriété. Donc
euh
encore une fois, ce qui ça sert à quoi
d'être très riche si on a une vie sobre
? Enfin, je veux dire donc la richesse
à aider les autres, à aider aider le
pays
par exemple. Ouais, par exemple. Voilà.
Mais très bien, ça me va. Donc euh
quand on quand on quand on se contente
d'une vie sobre, on s'aperçoit que son
argent peut le servir peut servir à des
choses intelligente plutôt que de euh
d'être en en jet priv. Tiens, je vais
vous dire une statistique qu'on a
découvert en faisant le PTEF. T'amusant,
c'est le l'aviation d' d'affaires, hein.
L'aviation d'ide d'affaires, on a
regardé les les chiffres de la DGAC. Ça
c'est assez rigolo parce qu'il y a 95 %
des vols qui sont des vols à titre
privé. Ça c'est une statistique de la
DGAC hein. Donc c'est pas nous qui
l'avons inventé. On a dénoncé 95 des %
des vols en France de voilà sont des
vols à titre privé. Voilà. Et les deux
lignes qui marchent le plus c'est Paris
Nice et Nice Moscou. Voilà. Donc c'est
juste voilà, c'est une illustration de
ce qu'on découvre quand on fait ce
travail secteur par secteur. Donc il y a
pas de jugement de valeur là-dedans. Il
y a juste de dire voilà l'aviation
privée aujourd'hui euh enfin l'aviation
dite d'affaires, elle sert beaucoup
à des déplacements privés. Donc ça c'est
un usage, c'est pas parce que ces avions
sont éventuellement la propriété des
gens qui les utilisent, mais pas que.
C'est un usage qui qui pose question
voilà de l'avion parce que ça c'est une
consommation extrême de CO2 pour faire
quelque chose qui est d'aller de Paris à
Nice et de Nice à Paris le dimanche soir
quand on rentre. Bon, on peut se
demander quel est le vrai la vraie le
vrai caractère indispensable de ces deux
déplacements hein et si les gens
pourraient pas mieux comme le faisait
Jean-Marc partir en train
l'humour de monsieur Estrosi.
Voilà
Jean-Marc la démographie.
Bah, la démographie, c'est un des termes
de l'équation. C'est-à-dire que à partir
du moment où on est euh
à devoir partager un espace qui est-ce
qu'il est et des ressources qui sont ce
qu'elles sont, plus on est nombreux
autour de la table de repas et plus les
règles de partage sont compliquées ou
subtiles ou parfois longues à mettre en
œuvre. Donc oui, il y a un sujet
démographique dans notre équation, c'est
absolument évident. Alors,
on a deux manières de prendre le
problème. On peut le prendre sur le plan
philosophique, c'est-à-dire est-ce que
on est pour, contre, les et cetera et on
peut le prendre sous l'angle pratique.
Alors, comme on est ici pour parler du
plan de transformation de l'économie
française, on va le prendre sous cet
angle pratique. J'ai pas une manière de
voter en touche, c'est une manière de
recentrer sur ce qui sur avec quelle
hypothèse on va travailler à l'horizon
de 5 ans, parce que c'est ça notre plan
de transformation, c'est les mesures
qu'on doit mettre en œuvre dans les 5
ans qui viennent. En fait, l'équation
démographique, elle est pas tellement en
cause parce que sauf épisode de type
Donup, euh la démographie en France dans
les 5 ans qui viennent, c'est à quelques
pourcents près le nombre de gens queon a
aujourd'hui. Et à partir du moment où
dans les 5 ans, on doit baisser les
émissions de 25 %,
la variation de la démographie est un
facteur de deuxème ordre par rapport à
ce qu'on doit faire sur tout un tas
d'autres
facteurs. Donc j'ai envie de dire c'est
pas notre premier problème si on regarde
la France et les 5 ans qui viennent.
Voilà.
Question internet. Pourquoi on n pas des
startups dans l'énergie dans le
traitement des déchets ?
Il y en a. Nord,
sauf que c'est pas des start-ups dont
parle la presse, j'imagine, et dont
parle notre président.
Vous avez des noms des noms que vous
connaissez
euh dans l'énergie ? Alors, je sais pas
si on peut les appeler des start-up,
mais vous avez aujourd'hui plein de
petites entreprises
qui gèrent des petits réseaux de
chaleur. Par exemple, euh vous avez des
petites entreprises qui produisent des
pellettes en bois euh pour le chauffage.
Euh vous avez des petites entreprises
qui installent des pompes à chaleur,
s'appelle des artisans, donc des
start-ups dans l'énergie au sens large,
il y en a plein. Simplement, ça fait pas
la une des journaux. Euh et ça ne ça
n'est pas valorisé socialement. Il y a
il y a un vrai sujet dans notre affaire
qui est la valorisation sociale de ce
qu'on fait. Euh on le voit bien par
exemple dans la recherche, vous avez
plein de gens qui font un doctorat et un
post-doctorat et continuent à être payé
au SMIC. Et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils le
font ? Alors queon pourrait se dire avec
la cervelle qu'ils ont, ils ont qu'à
faire de la finance comme l'ant je
plante euh enfin je veux dire pourquoi
est-ce qu' juste parce que à un moment
il y a plein de gens pour qui le côté
socialement valorisant est important et
le sens est important.
les autres cupides,
c'est des bah vous savez si je regarde
pour les gens de ma génération qui sont
allés dans la finance parce que j'en ai
quand même quelques-uns, souvent ceux
qui y sont allés
ils sont tristes.
Je vais pas dire qu'ils sont tristes,
mais il y en a beaucoup qui sont allés
un peu par défaut. C'est-à-dire que à ce
moment-là, il y avait rien d'autre qui
les passionnait. Non, c'est pas ça.
C'était c'est il y avait rien d'autre
qui les passionnait plus que ça. Donc
ils sont dit "Bon, je vais aller gagner
de l'argent au moins derrière comme ça
j'aurai la vie facile." Et voilà, les
gens qui étaient vraiment passionnés par
quelque chose, ils ont fait ce qui les
passionnait.
Laurent, pourquoi tu vous avez fait ?
Non, mais moi j'ai pas fait finances,
j'ai fait je me suis occupé d'abord de
je finançais des actifs, donc des
voitures, des camions, de l'immobilier.
Voilà. Donc c'était ce qui
m'intéressait, c'était les choses,
c'était les produits que je manipulais.
Donc j'étais déjà dans les choses, dans
la ressource, dans les usages.
Voilà. Et c'est pour ça que je me suis
intéressé aussi au ces problématiques
d'énergie parce que moi j'ai vu les
usages changer. Voilà, j'ai j'ai vu ce
qui se passait avec mon prisme.
Alors ça tombe bien, on a un un prisme
d'un financier et un prisme d'un
ingénieur spécialisé dans l'énergie. Non
mais je le taquine mais Laurent est pas
financier. Il est
les cryptoonnaies.
Ah alors
c'est bien, c'est pas bien ? Est-ce que
ça peut financer l'économie verte ?
Est-ce que ça ça fait que des trous dans
le réseau électrique ? Est-ce que
Alors ça fait des trous dans le réseau,
ça fait des trous je la dire quelque
chose enfin ça fait il y a des
consommations d'énergie considérables
qui sont liées au mining hein. Ça c'est
c'est objectif.
On va parler du crédit carbone basé sur
de la crypto euro qui serait une monnaie
comment
ça fait beaucoup de crypto
ouais
techno solution
pipo chose ça parce que alors ça c'est
très très loin de nos bases tout ça dans
le plan de transformation de l'économie
française on parle de choses réelles qui
parlent aux gens d'usage concret et
encore une fois on écarte la
problématique monétaire, la
problématique de la matéri la convention
de la transaction. Donc c'est une autre
convention de la transaction, le
Bitcoin, hein, plutôt qu'une monnaie
normale,
on achète une monnaie dont le dont la
valeur est garantie par un par un
algorithme plutôt que par le fait que ce
soit adossé à un état, mais ça centrale
ou une banque centrale, c'est pareil.
Euh bon mais c'est loin c'est loin de
nos affaires. Donc le seul le seul point
où on observe ce qui se passe du point
de vue de ces cryptomonnaies, c'est dans
l'utilisation qui est faite des data
center pour fabriquer ces
cryptomonnaies, hein. Et donc là, il y a
des consommations d'énergie
considérables.
Les data centers.
OK. Est-ce qu'on va réouvrir des
centrales à Fenheim ?
Non.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est
enfin est-ce qu'on va réussir on
pourrait en construire une nouvelle mais
celle qui existe, celle qui est en
place, on peut pas la réouvrir.
C'est c'est cuit.
C'est cuit.
Est-ce que le nucléaire ça va devenir
une énergie prédominante dans la
transition ?
Ça dépend à quel horizon de temps.
Si on regarde les 5 années qui viennent,
non. Enfin, ça dépend, on parle de la
France, on parle du monde.
On parle de la France et c'est directeur
à 13 réacteurs à l'arrêt en
intermittence.
Alors, il y a les 13 réacteurs
actuellement à l'arrêt en intermittence.
Je je je comprends la question.
Bah c'était une boutade. C'estd que là
là on va être obligé de mettre nos
réacteurs en intermittence pour faire la
la la rénovation d'une partie un
carinage.
Ah
le côté corrosion de certains tuyaux.
Ah d'accord. Euh pourquoi 13 ? Parce
qu'il y en a d'autres qui viennent de
c'est 10 ou 13. 10.
On a tr France info à faire sur trois
nouveaux.
Il y a trois nouveaux qui sont au caraf
là.
Ah d'accord.
Euh alors ça je en l'occurrence c'est
une actualité que qui m'échappe.
C'est notre petite paire de deux.
Euh d'accord. Euh ce que j'ai compris
sur ceux qui ont déjà été mis à l'arrêt
euh c'est que en fait on a découvert une
corrosion sur des dispositifs qui sont
des dispositifs à utiliser en cas
d'urgence. Euh donc c'est normal queon
ait pas trouvé le défaut dans le
fonctionnement normal du réacteur. Euh
et une fois qu'on a trouvé le défaut,
évidemment la SN met le réacteur à
l'arrêt en disant il faut corriger ce
truclà. Euh
du coup, c'est quoi la question ?
La question c'est est-ce qu'on va
refaire du nucléaire comme notre
président ?
Ah, on est aujourd'hui alors ce qu'il
faut comprendre aujourd'hui, c'est que
il y a pas de situation simple. Euh,
j'en reviens à ce que je disais, il y a
pas de solution simple
dans les énergies
décarbonées qui sont à notre
disposition.
On a deux familles, on a l'énergie
nucléaire ou exactement les énergies
nucléaires parce qu'il y a plusieurs
manières de faire et les énergies
renouvelables.
Les énergies renouvelables,
il y en a un certain nombre qui sont
limités par euh
les éléments géographiques. Par exemple,
hydroélectricité, faut des montagnes. La
biomasse, il faut des surfaces couvertes
de biomasse, enfin l'électricité à base
de biomasse ou les biocarburants ou les
et cetera. Il faut il faut des des
surfaces où on puisse faire pousser des
choses et qu'on ait pas besoin
d'utiliser pour soit manger euh soit
faire manger nos animaux
ou soit faire du carburant.
Si à ce moment c'est justement c'est de
l'énergie
ça fait partie des énergies
renouvelables si on fait du biocarburant
avec de la biomasse.
Sauf que il faut pas avoir besoin de
cette biomasse pour manger. Ça vient en
concurrence avec le avec le
l'alimentation.
Sinon ça fait quoi les émeutes de la fin
? Bah sinon, ça fait euh une moindre
disponibilité alimentaire euh qu'on peut
compenser de deux manières. On peut la
compenser d'une première manière en
diminuant la quantité de viande qu'on
mange. Euh ça c'est une première manière
qu'on qu'on a de de compenser. Et une
deuxième manière euh c'est euh d'avoir
moins de gens qui mangent. Donc la
deuxième manière est plus agréable.
Et enfin
on a le vent et le le vent et le soleil.
Mais en fait, le vent et le soleil euh
demandent des quantités de matériaux
importantes pour être mis en œuvre euh
parce que c'est des énergies qui sont
diffuses et donc ça demande des
quantités de métal importantes. Euh il y
a l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
qui a sorti un rapport il y a pas très
longtemps pour faire des ordres de
grandeur. Euh et par exemple le solaire
demande par kilwh 10 fois plus de cuivre
que les modes concentrés, on va dire euh
nucléaire, charbon, gaz. Voilà. Sauf que
gaz et charbon, on en veut pas parce que
c'est a du CO2. Donc si on compare au
nucléaire, ça pourrait 10 fois plus.
Le
aucune solution n'est parfaite.
C'est-à-dire que si on se dit on compte
sur le nucléaire,
la limite est une limite de compétence
euh et une limite réglementaire parce
que là en l'occurrence les réacteurs
qu'on arrête, on pourrait très bien se
dire ça c'est comme c'est comme une
voiture dont tout d'un coup les feux
arrières tombent en panne. Euh
formellement ça vous interdit pas de
rouler.
Les gaines les gaines qui entourent les
crayons de combustible, ils sont faits à
partir de quoi déjà ?
Zirconium. Il y a pas de pénurie sur
leconium.
Bah, c'est une affaire de quantité de
matière mise en jeu par kilow produit.
C'est-à-dire que le nucléaire étant une
énergie très dense, euh, il met en œuvre
moins de métal par kilow produit que les
énergies renouvelables qui sont moins
denses. Ça c'est de la physique de base,
ça voilà ça. Après, c'est pas
nécessairement les mêmes métaux mais
globalement la dépendance au métal
encore une fois tout compris est plus
faible quand le type d'énergie qu'on
utilise est plus concentré.
Euh donc pour en revenir à la à ce que
je disais, sur le nucléaire, on a des
limites de compétences et de
réglementation
surtout.
Euh c'est c'est ça le c'est ça la c'est
ça les limites. Euh et euh pour
reprendre l'exemple que je viens de
citer là, les réacteurs qui sont mis à
l'arrêt, c'est un peu comme si vous êtes
dans une voiture dont tout d'un coup les
feux arrières s'éteignent. Formellement,
ça vous empêche pas de rouler mais vous
augmentez le risque de rouler. Et après,
c'est un arbitrage des risques. C'est un
peu comme la diga Fukushima.
C'est un arbitrage des risques.
C'est-à-dire que si à l'intérieur de la
voiture, vous avez votre gamin en train
d'agoniser, vous posez pas la question,
vous dites "Je continue à rouler." Euh
si vous avez tout le temps devant vous
et que vous avez vous avez une voiture
pas très rapide et que il y a des gens
qui arrêtent pas de vous dépasser, vous
dit "Je m'arrête et puis je vais réparer
les je vais faire réparer les phares".
Donc c'est une affaire d'arbitrage des
risques. Donc là le nucléaire c'est
exactement ça. C'est il y a une limite
en compétence parce que c'est compliqué
de faire une centrale et il y a une
limite il y a une limite réglementaire
qui est liée à notre conception à
l'instant donné de l'arbitrage des
risques. Sur les renouvelables, les
risques sont pas de même nature. Donc
sur le nucléaire, il y a un risque de
pas arriver à faire à cause de ce que je
viens d'évoquer. sur les renouvelables,
il y a un risque de pas arriver à faire
parce que c'est différent de faire une
éolienne ou un panneau solaire et un
système complet avec des éoliennes et
des panneaux solaires. Le système
complet n'a pas besoin que d'une
éolienne ou d'un panneau solaire. Donc
faire une éolienne ou un panneau
solaire, ça va vite, ça c'est clair. Par
contre, faire un système complet, ça va
pas nécessairement plus vite. Et ça ne
ça demande autre chose que des
dispositifs de production. Il faut des
dispositifs de stockage
et il faut éventuellement mutualiser
avec des pays étrangers, donc augmenter
ce qu'on appelle les interconnexions.
Mais augmenter ce qu'on appelle les
interconnexions, c'est augmenter par
construction la dépendance à nos
voisins. Donc ça veut dire que on se
rend un peu plus dépendant de ce qu'ils
voudront bien faire eux.
Euh et donc ça veut dire que si on
compte sur eux pour nous fournir de
l'électricité quand il y en a pas assez
chez nous, il faut qu'on il faut qu'il
l'ai. Donc ça dépend un peu plus de ce
qu'ils vont faire eux. Le les risques
sur le stockage, c'est que on n'y arrive
pas, c'est qu'on ait pas les dispositifs
de stockage. Le risque sur le
déploiement des dispositifs de
production, c'est qu'on narrive pas à
les déployer assez vite et en assez
grande quantité parce qu'on va buter sur
des problèmes de disponibilité en métal,
de disponibilité en emplacement, de
voilà. Et enfin, le risque sur les
interconnexions, c'est soit qu'on les
fasse pas, soit que nos voisins n'aient
pas l'électricité disponible quand nous
on en a besoin. Donc en fait, un système
sans risque à partir d'aujourd'hui, ça
n'existe plus. Voilà, c'est ça quand
même la grande leçon qu'il faut qu'il
faut garder en tête. Ça n'existe pas ça.
Ça n'existait déjà pas avant qu'on
découvre le problème. OK là et de toute
façon, ça n'existe pas. C'est ça. Et
c'est compliqué euh pour beaucoup de
gens de comprendre que euh on passe d'un
système dans lequel on enfin d'un mode
de raisonnement dans lequel on pouvait
penser qu'il y avait un truc qui allait
bien sans risque versus d'autres trucs
qui avaient des risques. Ah de toute
façon, il va falloir qu'on arbitre les
risques. C'est compliqué.
Un petit commentaire pour Laurent qui
vient de notre chat. On voit ce que ça
donne dans les épas de la main invisible
du marché.
Non.
Ouais. Euh je sais pas si je connais pas
le l'is épad et les dysfonctionnements
qui qui étaient en cause. CPA,
vous prévoyez quoi pour votre vos vieux
jours ? Ah puis on est encore vachement
jeune avant de se poser ces questions
là. Je pense que c'est des trucs qu'on
anticipe jamais ça. Ouf !
Je suis pas sûr que ça se passe de
prévoyance. Pas de prévoyance.
Bah non, on n pas là-dedans.
Vous avez stocké votre épargne sur quel
type de de plan financier ? un peu
agressif, un peu sur les marchés
extérieurs, sur les matières premières.
Non, je suis pas très bon pour gérer ces
trucs-là, donc ça m'occupe pas beaucoup.
Ouais. J'ai pas je calcule pas. Ouais.
Oh bah, ça c'est une chance.
Ouais. Ouai. Mais pour revenir aux
épades, non mais euh en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que
euh il y a un problème de définition de
la norme. C'est un peu comme central
nucléaire dans cette affaire, c'est
définition de la norme de de service qui
n'est pas uniforme en fait. Donc vous
avez, si je comprends bien ce dossier
là, mais qui est un peu éloigné de nos
sujets, mais
il y a pas il y a pas de norme de
service défini ou suffisamment défini et
il y a pas suffisamment de d'organismes
de contrôle si j'ai bien compris et donc
ça laisse une grande latitude et et si
j'ai bien compris hein le dossier alors
ma question ma question est un peu
provoquée
donc c'est pas ça pas grandchose à voir
avec la finance en vérité à mon avis
en fait c'est c'est la question que je
vous pose c'est est-ce que vous avez
réfléchi à ce qu'on fait des vieux parce
que le vieux qui vieillit coûte très
cher le vieux qui vieillit.
Pas sûr qu'il qu'ils émettent beaucoup
de de CO2 les vieux.
Ils ont des vies assez peu émétrices à
mon avis.
Le côté social de la fin de vie, vous
aviez vous y avez pensé dans le le chift
?
C'est pas un c'est pas un angle qu'on a
regardé de façon explicite dans le plan
de transformation de l'économie
française. Non.
OK. Question internet. Accepteriez-vous
un poste de ministre de l'énergie ? Si
oui, quelle serait votre première mesure
?
Tu acceptes un poste de ministre de
l'énergie toi ?
Moi je pense que
ce que je fais aujourd'hui avec le
groupe de gens avec lequel je fais
c'est plus efficace qu'un ministre.
Je pense qu'on fait de la politique.
Oui, je pense qu'on aide les gens à
faire de la politique et je pense que
pour les quelques années qui viennent,
ce qu'on est en train de faire là avec
le groupe de gens avec lesquels on
travaille, je pense qu'on a du poids.
Ouais, j'ai assez confiance dans ça.
Voilà. Donc aujourd'hui, moi je trouve
que les politiciens, moi je j'en connais
pas mal et je admire, il y a des gens
qui font qui se qui se défoncent pour ce
qu'ils font. Il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres gens moins recommandables, mais
je trouve pas qu'ils aient tant de
l'attitude que ça, tant le temps de
réfléchir. Voilà. Donc moi aujourd'hui,
je trouve que voilà, on est bien dans ce
qu'on fait pour le projet qu'on a.
Question internet,
bonsoir. Question simple. Les jeux ne
sont-ils pas déjà faits ? Alors moi je
vais je vais le traduire. Allez à
Jacques Taist.
Je crois qu'on a déjà répondu à la
question tout à l'heure.
Très bien.
Alors on va
je je suis désolé. J'espère queil ne va
pas la personne qui a posé cette
question ne va pas prendre ça pour une
horrible vexation.
Mais je crois qu'on a déjà traité de la
question.
Est-ce que vous avez des sujets que vous
voulez que qu'on aborde un peu plus en
détail ?
Est-ce que Ouais est-ce qu'il y a un
point qui vous semblerait hyper
important dans The Shift Project
qu'on a pas abordé ce soir ? Euh
ouais. Allez, je vais me je vais me je
vais me lancer un tout à l'heure Laurent
a parlé de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat en disant que c'était
intéressant de voir comment euh ça avait
transformé les gens qui avaient
participés qui étaient devenus beaucoup
plus mordu sur le sujet. Et en fait, je
vais élaborer un peu là-dessus parce que
je pense que au chiffre Project, on a
exactement le même genre de processus.
Euh et je vais insister sur un mot il a
déjà été prononcé qui est euh enfin il a
pas été prononcé en tant que tel mais il
renvoie quelque chose qui a déjà été
prononcé qui est le mot de collectif.
Euh là on va parler de construction mais
c'est pareil de coconstruction et
collectif. Euh ce ce il se trouve que
c'est nous deux qui sommes là ce soir
mais en fait on est la partie
émergée d'un très très gros iceberg.
Euh et ce qui est très important, il me
semble, euh c'est d'essayer de faire des
choses de manière collective. Euh
on a confiance que dans un truc qu'on a
contribué à élaborer. Euh et donc on
peut pas avoir un plan et proposer un
plan euh si euh on n'embarque pas les
gens. Non seulement c'est c'est pas
assez de les embarquer dans le résultat,
il faut les embarquer dans
l'élaboration. Euh c'est pour ça que on
est qu'au début du processus. C'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure et tant
mieux s'il nous reste des choses à
faire.
Je peux me couper ?
Ouais.
Les gens qui on qui ont participé à ce
processus,
ils font quoi dans la vie ? Ils ont du
temps. Ils ont il y en a plein que je
connais il y en a plein que je connais
pas. Il y a
Ils ont du temps, ils ont
des shifters, il y en a 16000 donc je
les connais pas.
Oui, je sais pas. Mais
embarquer les autres quand ils ont la
tête dans le guidon, résister à l'ur
résister à l'impression, c'est un défi
et c'est une de nos envies tous
les jours. Payer les factures.
Et ben c'est une de nos envies. Euh
c'est bien les envies. Oui, en général,
un projet commence par une envie.
C'est-à-dire qu'une envie fait pas un
projet, mais un projet sans envie, c'est
compliqué. Donc comme l'action sur du
rêve,
il faut commencer par le commencement.
Donc on commence par une envie.
Je suis désolé.
C'est quoi votre rêve ?
Euh une question à la fois. Donc je me
souviens très mal de mes rêves. Euh donc
pour en revenir à la
c'est de réveiller euh le rêve
je après la question après euh donc dans
les dans les choses qui nous paraissent
être importantes encore une fois c'est
que euh il faut pas que ce plan soit
juste une production qu'on propose, il
faut aussi que ce soit une dynamique.
Et donc aujourd'hui on a des tas
d'envies sur la manière d'associer
d'autres personnes, d'aller discuter
avec plein de gens. Euh je parlais tout
à l'heure des organisations syndicales.
On a essayé pour le moment on n pas
encore arrivé mais on continue
d'essayer. Moi, j'aimerais bien par
exemple queil y ait un certain nombre de
qu' qu'on y a un certain nombre de gens
dans ces organisations qui disent "Mais
tiens, moi il y a un sujet sur lequel
j'ai envie de provoquer un débat euh sur
les mesures du plan. Euh donc je autour
de moi là euh dans ma boîte euh dans ma
et cetera ou dans les quelques
entreprises où je suis représenté, je
vais chercher des gens euh et puis je
leur je les mets autour d'une table et
puis on leur présente ce qu'il y a
dedans et puis on leur dit "Vous en
pensez quoi ?" Bon voilà voilà un truc
qui me paraît intéressant. Qu'est-ce que
vous auriez envie d'ajouter ? et puis on
discute. Ah oui, ça c'est facile, ça
c'est moins facile, ça c'est pas
possible pour telle raison, j'en sais
rien.
Euh donc le le une de nos envies, c'est
de continuer cette démarche
collaborative sans laquelle en fait il y
a il y a pas de mouvement qui tiennent
quoi. Il y a pas de il y a pas de il y a
pas d'adhésion qui puisse se construire.
Euh voilà, donc ça c'est un des trucs
dont on avait me semble-t-il pas parlé
ou pas suffisamment parlé jusqu'à
maintenant et j'insiste vraiment
là-dessus et par ailleurs, ça n'i
l'occasion de voir un truc qui est
évident qui est que la coconstruction ça
rend optimiste. C'estd que quand les
gens commencent à réfléchir à l'avenir
qu'ils pourraient construire, même si
c'est plein de contrainte, si on arrive
à les embarquer dans cette dynamique, ça
ça donne ça ça ça donne la pêche, quoi.
Je veux dire, faire un projet souvent ça
ça dynamise.
Euh et donc il a c'est vraiment un
élément sur lequel je crois c'est
important d'insister. Euh ça marchera
pas vu l'effort que il faut que on
s'impose à nous-même si on n'est pas
dans un processus dans lequel le le le
gens ont envie d'aller et et et et il
faut que
il faut que ça soit fait de manière
collective parce que c'est la
contrepartie euh du fait que les gens
ont envie d'y aller et on l'a très bien
vu avec la convention citoyenne pour le
climat. Verra-ton un crédit carbone par
personne comme un crédit social un
crédit social rationnant la consommation
?
Bah j'espère pas.
J'espère pas parce que ça serait bien
triste d'en arriver à cette à cette
triste on enfin on espère pas que on en
arrive à cette triste comptabilité.
Euh je pense que ce qui est enfin nous
je pense que ce dont on a envie c'est
que les gens euh prennent conscience des
enjeu et envie de changer euh par
eux-mêmes individuellement ou
collectivement. Euh donc ça serait bien
dommage qu'on en arrive à cette espèce
de
de police des mœurs ou
carbonique.
Un premier ministre
qu'il faudrait s'imposer.
Un premier ministre. Si vous étiez
premier ministre, la première mesure du
shift que vous allez faire passer,
ça c'est un c'est une question pour
candidat à l'élection présidentielle.
Vous allez les les étrier un petit peu
ce que je ce que je ne suis pas
à tous.
Pourquoi vous voulez pas ?
Alors une question une question à la
fois déjà, il faut réponde à la question
sur mes rêves. J'en ai j'ai trois
questions de retard. Euh donc
il y a je crois un débat
dans une primaire
si c'est pas la primaire de la droite je
sais plus encore. Bref, j'avais regardé
un débat une primaire et il y avait une
journaliste connue, je sais plus
laquelle mais bon bref qui avait posé
exactement cette question au candidat à
la primaire. Si vous êtes élu, c'est
quoi la première truc ou à la première
des vers, je sais plus. Enfin bref,
c'est quoi la première mesure que vous
mettez en œuvre ? Et alors je me suis
dit pauvre candidat obligé de répondre à
une question aussi idiote. Pardon, je
suis désolé hein. Parce que quand on
propose
voisin derrière
Oui, absolument.
parce que quand on propose euh
quand on propose une construction
globale,
où est la mesure la plus importante dans
un truc global ? Il y en a pas.
Pourquoi est-ce que je dirais que de
former les gens, c'est plus important
que de de commencer à limiter le nombre
de crédaux de décollage. J'en sais rien.
À partir du moment où il faut faire
plusieurs plein de trucs en même temps,
il y a pas une mesure,
il y a pas des trucs à prioriser en
priorité.
Voilà. Et alors sinon, je peux faire
répondre par une boutade en disant je
suis premier ministre. La première
décision que je prends c'est d'aller
pisser parce que c'est probablement la
première envie que j'aurais à court
terme. Donc enfin non mais voilà. Donc
il a il y a c'est justement je pense que
c'est
considérer que le le problème est
excessivement simple que de considérer
que il y a une mesure cardinale qu'il
faut absolument prendre et qui va déjà
commencer à résoudre une bonne partie du
problème pendant que le reste serait un
peu moins nécessaire. Non, quand on fait
un plan d'ensemble, on applique le plan
quoi. Voilà.
La
ben oui, parce que c'est pour ça qu'il
faut une planification. Tous les gens
ont une part du puzzle chacun dans leur
dans leur dans leur secteur. Oui. Et ils
ont une part de la solution mais qui ne
marche.
Ouais, on peut dire ça comme ça. Ouais,
on peut dire ça en français. On peut
dire ils ont un bout de la solution.
Voilà. Mais la solution, elle marche que
si tout le monde fait fait son bout de
solution en même temps. C'est comme des
engrenages qui d'une machine la machine
ne tourne que si tous les engrenages
tournent à la fois. S'il y en a un seul
qui a pas compris, qui tourne pas, c'est
arrêté. Donc
vous pensez que la finance, elle a elle
a compris là.
Mais la finance la finance encore une
fois, elle est suiviste. La la finance
c'est la c'est la contrepartie de la
réalité économique. Euh c'est la
contrepartie monétaire des réalités de
consommation de biens et de services par
une société. Donc c'est rien d'autre que
ça.
C'est quoi la la poursuite du rendement
à gogo.
C'est quoi un fond vautour ?
Je sais pas,
c'est des mots mais c'est des mots mais
Non mais il y a il y a des bons et des
mauvais. Il y a des gens courttermistes
et des gens intelligents. Euh
en général, ils sont ils sont ils sont
toujours placés là où ils font le plus
de nuisance. C'est ça.
En tout cas, la finance, elle doit être
au service de la transition. Elle ne
peut pas prétendre être l'alpha et
l'oméga de la transition. Voilà. Donc et
de toute façon
la finance enfin ou l'argent ou les
taxes ou les aides ou le capital de
quelque manière qu'on le qu'on le
regarde,
il ne sera s'alloué correctement que si
on a décrit la solution technique et
humaine. Donc de toute façon euh la
transformation de l'économie, elle passe
d'abord par une description des flux
physiques et des compétences nécessaires
pour mettre en œuvre ces
transformations. La question reformulée
de mon voisin de derrière. Est-ce qu'il
accepterait un poste de premier ministre
pour mettre en place son plan ? Il est
le mieux placé ? Non,
je vais faire euh Non, en fait, on est
dans un régime présidentiel, donc le
mieux placé s'appelle le président de la
République. Euh il y a qu'à voir en ce
moment l'actuel premier ministre et
l'actuel président de la République. Et
on comprend tout de suite qu'il porte la
culotte. Euh donc bah oui, je comprends
tout de suite qu'il porte la culotte.
Donc euh c'est Non, mais euh euh donc je
vais faire une réponse 1 euh qui pour
partie va être la même que Laurent,
c'est-à-dire euh je suis très content
d'être là où je suis. Euh je n'ai pas
d'ambition. Euh c'est un autre métier
hein euh d'être d'être chef de
gouvernement hein. C'est c'est pas le
mien.
Euh il y a des tas de domaines sur
lesquels il faut prendre positions sur
lesquelles aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
d'avis où je ne vois pas au nom de quoi
le travail que j'ai déjà fait me
donnerait un avis particulièrement
éclairé. euh je sais pas euh euh la la
gestion des courants religieux en
France, je vois pas pourquoi mon avis il
ferait particulièrement autorité euh au
au motif que euh j'en connais un peu
plus long que les autres sur le pétrole
ou sur le changement climatique. Donc il
y a il y a plein de domaines euh qui
relèvent de de la construction sociale
euh où j'ai pas de compétences
particulières. Euh par ailleurs, le le
chiffre Project fait de la politique
puisque on propose euh des mesures qui
sont dans le champ euh du politique.
Sur internet, quel est le candidat le
plus en phase avec le PTEF ?
On nen sait rien. Par contre, ce qu'on
sait,
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
allez appeler à voter
? Non, on va le pos on va leur poser la
question,
c'estàd qu'on va leur demander à chacun,
on va faire un truc en deux temps, euh
on va leur demander de décrire dans leur
terme à eux et en trois pages ce qu'ils
ont l'intention de faire dans notre
domaine
avec un petit crayon de couleur
et veulent et on publiera les réponses
et non seulement on publiera les
réponses mais on publiera le commentaire
que nous allons faire sur les réponses
au stylo rouge
au stylo rouge ouvert mais de préférence
pas dans la couleur de la copie parce
que sinon on voit pas les corrections
Non, on corrigera pas, on donnera un
avis et euh
mieux faire.
On donnera un avis et à
droit dans le mur.
Si vous voulez faire partie du jury, on
peut discuter.
Grand plaisir.
Et euh dans l'autre sens euh on on va
enfin pas dans l'autre sens et on va par
ailleurs regarder leur programme
et on donnera également un avis sur les
programmes. Donc dans le sens où on
pousse, nous on a ce programme à nous en
disant bah voilà ce que nous on pense
qu'il faudrait faire et dans l'autre
sens on va leur demander de nous décrire
ce qu'ils ont l'intention de faire et
par ailleurs, on va s'emparer sans leur
rien leur demander de ce qui est écrit
dans leur programme et dans les deux cas
de figure, on donnera un avis.
C'est quand même un peu bâtard de faire
ça, non ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce queils ont pas les ressources
intellectuelles pour pouvoir répondre à
un programme digne de ce nom. Donc vous
allez débarquer. OK. Oh, il il pourrait
s'en doter.
Voilà, le le le premier effort, ce
serait de le premier effort, ça serait
de se mettre un tout petit peu à la
table de travail et puis de prendre les
choses. On leur a déjà donné
le plan dans le sens, on leur a donné
les têtes de chapitre, c'est pas mal
hein. qui pourrait déjà simplement avec
nos juste nos têtes de chapitre prendre
la peine de dire dans chacun des
registres et dans chacun des secteurs à
la limite si copie qu'on propose
on a proposé le corriger en même temps
que que les preuves. C'est sympa quand
même.
Question internet. Pourquoi the Je vais
le faire avec l'accent français, je suis
infiniment désolé. Pourquoi The Limite
of Limite tout grosse
n'a pas alerté à son époque et n'a pas
produit l'effet ? Pourquoi le livre du
du shift du shift ferait mieux ?
Et bien euh la réponse à la Je je vais
vous donner mon hypothèse.
Mon hypothèse c'est que ce travail qui
est un travail remarquable de dynamique
des systèmes euh a été fait d'abord il
est entré en résonance au moment où il a
été fait avec le premier choc pétrolier.
Euh de limite sur growth, c'est 1972.
Choc pétrolier 73 74. Voilà. Et et à
l'époque il a eu une résonance
extraordinaire. MOS il s'est baladé
partout. Le truc a été traduit en 24
langues, je crois. Enf je sais pas. Bon
bref
euh mais par contre la bonne question
que je enfin la question que je me suis
posé moi qui est presque la même que
celle-là, c'est pourquoi il n'a pas
donner lieu à une école académique euh
importante dit autrement. il avait
inventé une autre manière de faire de
l'économie qui était de repartir des
flux physiques et on pourrait se dire du
coup il y a plein de gens qui auraient
dû se dire mais oui c'est comme ça qu'il
faut réfléchir et donc voilà et je me
suis c'est ça la question que je me suis
posé et j'ai mis longtemps à trouver ce
que je crois être la réponse ce crois
c'est qu'en fait une école économique ne
peut se développer que si vous avez des
clients en face dit autrement que si
vous avez des gens intéressés à prendre
ce que vous leur dites pour en tirer des
mesures opérationnelles. Or Mose, il a
raisonné à l'échelle de la planète et il
y a pas de chef du monde.
Donc il avait pas de client. Non, mais
donc il n'avait pas de client parce que
personne ne pouvait dériver de ce que
Mos disait sur le monde dans son
ensemble des mesures économiques qui
était limité aux frontières dans
lesquelles euh depuis l'autre été de
Westfie les gens sont souverains. Euh
nous ce qu'on a pris le problème à
l'envers, d'où la discussion qu'on a eu
tout à l'heure sur pourquoi française
parce que justement on est parti nous du
traité de Westfallie et on a dit on va
s'occuper de ce que la France fait en
France. Bien, on va pas s'occuper de ce
que la France fait ailleurs. Donc ce
qu'on espère, je dis bien c'est qu'on
espère parce que c'est un paris notre
affaire, c'est que on va faire un peu
mieux que M. D'abord, on profite de ce
qu'a fait Mdose, c'est-à-dire que il y a
quand même un héritage intellectuel de
Mose. Il il a quand même infusé un
certain nombre de gens qui ont lu, relu,
fait autre chose qui s'en inspirait,
décliné et cetera.
Donc on on sans Mdoses, nous on
marcherait peut-être pas aussi bien. Et
ensuite euh le le plan qu'on propose
nous, c'est un plan, c'est pas de la
scénarisation et c'est des mesures
opérationnelles. Quand on dit tout à
l'heure on va s'occuper des slots de
décollage dans les aéroports, c'est pas
de la scénarisation mondiale, c'est
opérationnel et c'est à l'échelle
française. Voilà. Donc à partir du
moment où c'est beaucoup plus
opérationnel, euh on pense que ça ouvre
la voie à ce que ça se crante euh de
façon plus importante.
Laurent, trois bouquins.
Ah,
trois bouquins.
Un tout petit bouquin que j'aime bien.
L'argent.
Ah, j'étais sûr qu'il a dire ça.
Bah oui, l'argent. Charles Peggy 1913,
ça prend pas longtemps à lire et c'est
la première mondialisation. Il parle de
il parle de la sobriété en fait. Ça
c'est rigolo.
Quoi d'autre ? Le temps qu'il
réfléchisse Jean-Marc profite pour
réfléchir.
Non, pour l'instant c'est le c'est le
seul que qui me vient en tête tout de
suite là.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur votre table de
nuit en ce moment ?
Ah si, il y a la la société de
consommation de Baudria. Très bien. Je
recommande vivement.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur la table de nuit
de votre femme ?
Tiens, j'irai voir ce soir.
C'est le jour.
Ouais, c'est le jour.
Quoi d'autre ? Qu'est-ce que ça suffira
? Un bouquin qui vous a marqué dans
votre vie ?
Oh, la chartreuse de Parm.
Pourquoi ?
Je sais pas. C'est c'est un livre qui se
lit en une journée. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Réfléchissez-y. Je
vais poser la même question des trois
bouquins à Jean-Marc.
Trois bouquins
qui m'ont marqué ou trois bouquins que
je dis bouquin à conseiller.
Ah bah il y en a un qu'on vient de
citer, The Limits to Growth. Enfin plus
exactement.
Alors je crois que la version originelle
n'est pas disponible en français euh
celle de 1972 et moi c'est celle que je
préfère mais par contre elle est
disponible en anglais. Euh alors, je
vais pas conseiller euh le la version
disponible en français de de 30 ans
après parce que j'ai fait la préface,
donc je vais quand même pas me
conseiller moi-même.
Euh
moi, il y a un bouquin que qui m'a alors
c'est avec les bouquins qui m'ont marqué
hein, euh que je ressors en permanence
mais que j'ai vraiment trouvé. Enfin, ça
a été une espèce de révélation quand je
l'ai lu. C'est de la démocratie en
Amérique. Euh je trouve que c'est un
quelque chose de de magistral sur la
façon dont la société s'organise dans un
régime démocratique. Euh et on y lit des
trucs comme enfin Tocville voyait que la
démocratie allait engendrer la
publicité, l'égalisation des conditions
entre les hommes et les femmes,
le court termisme,
la consommation de masse, enfin c'est
juste hallucinant quoi. C'est c'est
c'est voilà donc bouquin aussi que très
extraordinaire.
Euh et puis euh
dans les
dans les autres livres à recommander euh
après les autres ils sont moins je sais
pas si je dois dire magistraux ou
transversaux. Ils sont intéressants mais
après j'ai plein de bouquins
intéressants mais là-dedans j'en ai
beaucoup. J'en ai plus d'un donc je sais
pas lequel je devrais sortir de mon
chapeau, quoi. Euh,
un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
Laurent.
Ah, il faut qu'il il faut qu'il reste il
faut qu'il fasse enfin il faut qu'il
laisse la place à leur imagination.
Voilà, il faut pas qu'il s'enferme, il
faut pas qu'il disent ça va être comme
ça. Il faut vraiment qu'
qu'il reste imaginatif. Ouais. Qu' se
projette dans un truc qui est pas
déterminé. Voilà.
Avec où sont lunettes roses ? Non, non,
même mais même euh
même la catastrophe, ça fait partie de
l'imagination. Mais non, ce que je veux
dire, on il vaut mieux savoir l'imaginer
pour mieux l'éviter, je veux dire.
D'accord. Donc euh ouais, il faut
vraiment que les gens fassent ce travail
de d'imagination. C'est de la
prospective. Et voilà.
Jean-Marc,
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Euh non, sinon, je voulais dans les dans
les livres qui m'ont dont je me souviens
avec émotion. Alors, mais c'est pas un
livre à recommander, mais euh il y a un
roman de Robert Mer qui s'appelle
Malville
euh qui raconte l'histoire d'un petit
groupe de d'une toute petite société
humaine qui se reforme après justement
la fin du monde. Espèce d'explosion
thermonucléaire enfin, on sais pas trop
bien quoi, un truc qui a tué à peu près
tout le monde.
Euh et c'est c'est un c'est un bouquin
dont je me je l'ai lu très jeune mais je
m'en souviens encore. Il y a eu un film
derrière qui était pas du tout à la
hauteur du bouquin euh et
qui m'a marqué parce que c'est ça
explore justement les les les un tout
petit peu les ressorts de l'arme humaine
mais dans une scénarisation que j'avais
que j'avais bien aimé. Voilà.
Euh un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Euh
difficile.
Une question internet. Dommage pas
beaucoup de questions sur les énergies
de demain. On a compris que le pétrole
c'est bientôt fini et que les panneaux
solaires et les olies ne suffiront pas.
Il il y a un truc intéressant à propos
des ENR que j'ai l'
énergie renouvelable
les énergies renouvelables, c'est qu'on
les voit
que c'est enfin j'ai quelqu'un qui m'a
dit ça l'autre jour, je trouvais ça
c'est la seule énergie qu'on voit parce
qu'elle prend beaucoup de place hein. Le
pétrole on le voit pas, il est il a été
fabriqué il y a 400 millions d'années.
Redouvelable non mais c'est rigolo et ça
prend de la place par terre au sol.
Voilà. Donc c'est on matérialise le fait
que bah oui, pour avoir quelques
kilwatt, faut bien tapisser quand même
un toit ou voilà et que et que c'est pas
gratuit quoi ou une éolienne, c'est
quand même un sacré bidule. Donc euh ça
c'est intéressant du point de vue pour
les citoyens de comprendre que l'énergie
c'est pas free lunch quoi. C'est pas un
truc qui vient de
de nulle part ou du fond des âges
puisque c'est le fossile qui nous qui
nous berce d'illusion sur le fait que
euh l'énergie euh est infiniment
disponible. quand elle est sous forme de
NR, on voit bien l'emprise quoi. Donc
ça, je pense que en terme de réflexion
sur la sobriété, ça joue un rôle mine de
rien.
Laurent vous a sauvé pour le conseil
pour les jeunes générations.
Euh, j'en ai deux, je crois. Euh,
le premier c'est de c'est c'est
d'être curieux.
Euh et le et le deuxième euh
enfin c'est un espoir plus qu'un plus
qu'un conseil, c'est d'arriver à former
des projets. Euh alors pourquoi je dis
être curieux ? Euh parce qu'être curieux
en général ça permet d'être informé. Euh
et être informé ça permet d'augmenter sa
zone de confort et la sécurité de ce
qu'on fait. Ça permet de faire plus de
choses qui vont réussir. Donc la
curiosité c'est pas du tout un vilain
défaut. Euh c'est quelque chose qui est
utile euh parce que ça permet de mieux
comprendre le monde dans lequel on vit
euh et le
et d'avoir la capacité à faire des
projets parce que c'est absolument
essentiel. Alors en fait, il faudrait
que je leur donne un conseil pour être
capable de faire des projets. Je sais
pas si une Martinale pour ça mais euh
c'est c'est ça que je leur souhaite. En
tout cas,
Jean-Marc, est-ce que vous pouvez
attraper le petit bouquin qu'il y a par
terre ? Je vais montrer la caméra.
Est-ce que la caméra peut se mettre sur
le petit bouquin ? Est-ce que Jean-Marc
peut faire un beau sourire ? Il faut
lire ce bouquin. Ça vous permettra de
mieux comprendre et d'appréhender vos
politique et ce qui nous attend.
Messieurs, je voulais vous remercier de
d'être venu ce soir pour en parler.
C'est très important et merci encore et
bonne soirée.
Merci. Bonne fin de soirée.
[Musique]